ah hello everyone i'm so nervous i'm so scared oh my gosh oh everyone's practicing so hard i'm oh i'm actually very nervous today but my team has been practicing very hard as well sorry we just got out of a scrim and we were like cooling down from our scrim um we had to like teams are scrimming teams have been practicing the last very hard the last two days so um it very scary so we're gonna do a little quick play we're not gonna leak any strats though because like it's best of one it's best of one so if we uh we have one one game versus each team one one game and the top two teams go into finals and then the other two we leave but no matter what happens i'm gonna be playing rank until it's good night dragons uh No matter Either I'm coping Or I'm celebrating It's one or the other Yes Also we're starting early The real matches start at 5 They want us to warm up Like I guess like warm up Like an hour early But then like I saw Duby hasn't started stream yet So I was just like Yay So I was
just like Okay it's not just me at least So I was just like Okay it's not just me like but we found out all of us found out like yesterday I think like late last night that we're supposed to um we're like they were like yeah one hour early one hour early but that like obviously oh my god sorry that's like their soundboard I need to turn that on I really um that is that's the soundboard I need to remember how to turn off like mute other people's soundboard.
Okay.
Mute soundboard.
There you go.
Wait.
What about...
Sorry, we're discussing strats.
I don't want to leak anything because like where everyone's trying not to leak anything because it's best of one and if they know our comps like everyone's doing it all the teams are doing it uh so like um if they know our comp it's like gg sorry all
right area yeah because like if they know our comp it's just target ben Yeah, it's just there's no it's rank bands.
There's no protect so it's like straight up rank bands So, you know, they get two bands.
We get two bands, but we're batting at the same time So like uh, but like people are like research everyone almost everyone locked their profiles too My team locked their profile as well because I was like locked a profile because like I noticed the other Like the cat the usual the the the rival players that actually play this game a lot they all instantly locked their profiles the moment like when they started practicing so I was like told my team lock your profiles like if they're gonna lock it we gotta lock it but so so so like we're trying not to like everyone everyone is like oh my gosh I know everyone's also having a lot of fun you know it's obviously it's a lot of fun too but it's very stressful for me because I got assigned captain um in a pre-assigned team um so uh okay okay i'm just gonna i need to copy and paste this so i remember what we're running um like i have like a guide on like okay we gotta we banned this we banned this i i just want to i hope we win one game that's
our goal our goal is to win one game i i i i believe in us we can do it i just i just want us to win one game
That's my goal with like how, yeah, I just want to win at least one.
All right, here we go.
Um, okay, all right, okay.
I'm ready also.
Are you all at?
Very quick play.
All right, I'm asking if they're ready for quick play now.
All right.
I'm on YouTube.
They're like, let's do share chat.
And I'm like, I'm on YouTube.
Hello, hello.
Hello.
All right.
I'll add you guys.
Yeah.
I was like, hey, guys.
Is everyone?
Yeah, I'm so nervous.
The best of one is like fucking with me right now.
What?
Best of one is the best, bro.
Because you guys know it's not.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Because think about it, right?
Think about it, right?
You go in and you alt immediately.
You're just going as hard as possible in the first game.
You let them know who's winning.
And it's us.
Oh, oh.
The fact that you can like make a really bad misplay and then just lose and get eliminated is scaring me.
That's the scary part.
I thought like There would be like It's like You know Round We each play one game And then we do group stages So it's like Yeah But it's best of one And then The two best player teams You guys have fun So I'm Yeah yeah Well it's like It's like It's like we're in pools And also top 16 At the same time Yeah You just gotta You just gotta rock with it You know Yeah okay I am Wait why can't I invite you guys To my team Yeah Why do you guys have to...
Oh, you blocked us.
I can request.
No, it's like...
Oh, you guys have to request?
Yeah, I like half of you.
No, I can't...
Oh, now I can.
Okay.
Join the team.
Yeah, you guys have a request to join me.
Apparently, I can't invite people.
I don't know why.
All right, so for this...
The black backline will play our usual characters.
The front...
You guys go wild.
The other three, you guys go wild.
Pick whatever the fuck you want.
can play whoever i want you guys play whoever the fuck you want because i know exactly who i'm playing yeah yes whoever you want guys oh it says like some of you guys are like in the uh in the game that's why okay yeah i was in i was in a practice yeah i was like wondering who am i missing oh you use it yeah yeah sorry the fps counter blocked you from from your invite all right queue this up whoa i wonder who we're playing first i wonder if like we all play at the same time or it's like one by one because it's like four hours i was like there's no way because matches are so fast it's like 20 minutes i was gonna say the first two matches we played simultaneously yeah i don't know i don't know if they want to cast both of them simultaneously yeah so i think they're just like we take turns we literally just wait here one by one until you'll need until like our game starts again like we're just here watching the other team play like yes well here's the thing i guess i'm ready wait aren't
we team one though we're team what we were we were first on the list i assume that makes us team one oh what list are we what there's a list look we are the list that we know whose team is whose team or you know what maybe it was alphabetical whoever right now maybe yeah yeah the back line like the supports we play are you guys play whatever the fuck you would because like you know if you guys play the what we're actually playing then we're no i'm not bro because i'm playing the thing or we're playing mind games right now we're doing mind games you know what we're actually playing might might actually be actually you know what we don't even need a tank for real we just kill them all yeah exactly i'm playing my main i'm playing my yeah yeah uh if any of you guys are streaming on twitch and want to join the shared chat thing i put a link in our team thing okay Okay.
I will join.
I am on YouTube.
I'm sorry.
Not.
I wanted to be on YouTube.
Hey, that's captain.
We bleed purple around here, cut.
That's captain.
Yeah, your captain's not even on Twitch.
Oh my god, I'm hitting all my shots.
Wait, they have a tank.
That's cheating.
Yo, what?
I just got two no reds.
Oh my god, this captain's white.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm joining share chat.
I'm sorry.
Oh, you're joining.
Oh, someone's throwing.
Yeah, I was joining too.
I was just okay.
Oh, I'll join after the game.
That's why I'm lagging, bro.
That's why my shotgun is here.
I legitimately do feel like I'm lagging.
Still?
What?
Yo, back the fuck up, Emma.
My PSP like the Cloud Fuel servers, you know?
I am lagging in one.
Wait, have I actually lagging at first?
I was just trying to like make an excuse.
I might actually be lagging.
Wait, what?
I think my frames are just dropping to be honest.
It might be because of my VTuber model.
Yeah, no, it does that.
Oh yeah, I'm using Fugies only.
Oh, okay.
I'll probably do that.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I have a 59 just because I do this too much.
Heavenly, if you don't kill one person, I'm like, I'm gonna...
Just one headshot, Heavenly.
Just one!
I have so you know what we can I do gambit on and then you all my DPS can just go at it like throw everything what all right I have gamma on five oh my god you're dead I'm just gonna wait I'm just gonna wait I don't understand how we're losing guys I wonder what can we do I don't know looking at this you know what I haven't hit a headshot yet Are you guys ready?
Yeah, I'm switching, I'm switching, I'm switching, I'm switching.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
This is a really cool.
Are you guys ready?
I'm going to rip it.
Go.
Okay.
Oh, I'm black.
I got one.
Nice.
See?
Ripped it.
Oh, my God.
They're cops almost dead.
That was awesome.
There you go.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
You did it.
Wow.
We swapped with you.
We literally just went to all three.
who is that we gotta take and things got easier whoa i'm staggering the hell out of this guy oh wait i didn't even see yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm letting him get away on purpose so is this like oh wait mantis is by herself come here mantis oh my god oh my gosh guys oh my god he doing here nice nice well nice kill oh my god amazing behold the might of all right good job yes that's not my problem good oh my god what the is going on here yeah we don't need all those else guys we no we needed those we definitely needed every no no we don't need it on them it's it's it's to like yeah that's what guys that is exactly what we're gonna do in the in the tournament too yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah for those who are wondering let's kill blade he's by himself yo there i got him he's dead oh my god i'm coming i anti four people i got i got cat nice oh i'm tight in the 10.
they have an iron man now yeah what are they gonna do about that all right iron man low zap oh my gosh i fucked up my dash all right am i on the whole backline i am the backline i'm out of here you left me bro what the bro hey listen i threw the hammer you would pull the whole one percent i could have given you a solo gambit all now you ain't getting one oh
to here yeah yeah we did i know we're supposed to be like seriously playing but um i gotta go answer the door oh i'll swap time imagine this was the official match where's my wallet uh oh wait we got pauses for the official match that's good oh what is this dude what is that oh that's just it's just damage it's just like you're such a projectile because of a gambit team up Are you guys like also still experiencing lives?
Not me.
I think it's Cloudfield servers in general.
He's one.
Nice.
We're ulting.
I'm sorry.
I got the Emma though.
Oh, he's anti.
Oh, it's fine.
I don't even know how to shield.
Oh, that's how you shield.
Okay, yeah, double Bubba.
I have Invis alt for this.
I've never played this guy before.
You can, for Invis alt, just use defensively.
Because they do have ultis soon by the way.
Do Invis first.
And then cloak later.
Okay.
Captain behind again.
I got you.
I can look him.
All right.
You're fine.
Oh, no.
He's so fast.
I'm just a little guy.
I don't have any anti, so.
Oh.
He got these.
Yeah, yeah, use this.
Nice.
Oh.
Nice, nice, nice.
When you get cloak all aggressively, do you want?
Clock called.
Nice, nice, nice.
Antide, Antide!
I'm leaving.
Oh, shit.
It's my friend.
He also hit the wall.
Yeah, brother.
Okay, right.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, no.
fibers in front, in chamber.
I'm no, I'm low, I'm low.
I'm pushing card, I'm pushing card.
I got you, I got you.
I'm looking cap.
There's a gambit behind playing Queen.
Oh, there's like a gambit behind.
I'm not in long.
That's fine.
You're fine, you're fine.
Antide in this?
What am I doing?
I'm looking blade.
Oh, you guys go.
Yes.
Yes, go.
Oh,
no.
I'll grab this.
I really want to go.
I got blade.
I got blades.
I'm looking cap.
I'm just diving back.
Iron man is one.
I got my right.
Thank you.
Cap cap one.
Cap one.
Nice.
I'm going with Vince.
And this one.
You have a daredevil?
Holy shit.
Nice.
Yay.
I'm looking.
Give him one.
Yeah, give him this one.
We keep pushing.
I'm looking Blade.
Blade low.
Yeah, we got it.
We got it.
I'm going back.
We need one on cards.
A thousand cards.
And we can use...
For this, if we get cloak all at first, you can use cloak all aggressively here.
Okay.
I have ulti, by the way.
Also, he said you got a bubble or cloak.
do that but I don't know if you can but I don't know if you have that in me I'll try you slow I got it okay so when you hear the iron metal just bubble or cloak okay use aggressively use your cloak all here use your cloak all right nice nice and I don't know if you did it but like I did you do it I'm gonna back I need healing.
I need healing.
He just dodged.
Any healing?
I'm dead.
You got this?
Here you go.
You got all.
Okay.
I bubble Wolverine though.
I'm Batman ulting.
Gambit won.
Nice.
Nice kills.
Oh my god.
Good job.
That was awesome.
Good job guys.
We did it.
Look at that guys.
We won our first match everyone.
Best of luck.
Yeah!
All of us did it.
We all did it.
And ironically, that was my first time playing Mag ever.
So glad you were here.
Hi!
Good luck.
Alex here.
Hi.
I just wanted to say thanks for being part of the event.
And we may be piping in like Doki or one of the captains like periodically throughout the event, like to do an interview, but maybe like after a round or two.
Just wanted to give you an update.
Okay.
thank you awesome have fun guys see you thank you for the invite wait i had a question um are we are the two matches going simultaneously or is one match going at a time and we just all watch the match that's going on uh every match should be on stream so you can just uh yeah just watch so we're waiting oh okay yeah you can just like co-stream basically okay okay at the same time okay okay sure yeah we we enabled uh co-streaming for everyone so even on youtube should be good oh uh you you could you could like just obs it i guess no no uh co-stream for youtube but if you want to you know broadcast it it's all good yeah okay um i'll talk with production just to make sure we're good there but yeah every match should be on stream so okay okay do you okay any other questions uh do we know which team is which teams are going
first one is um and i could find out which one i'm having production like organize the whole thing at this point um so yeah i'm i'm the event organizer so let me come back to you okay i'll be right back okay thank you okay thank you yeah no problem have fun maybe i worded those questions kind of weird we got this it's fine i don't know what that means uh yeah i don't know uh i think means we're allowed to stream it like sure like like you can stream to stream yeah okay because it's technically against the rules to stream another partner's content unless they give you explicit permission oh i didn't know that okay well it's it's one of those rules where like if you do it and the person gets mad they can report you but if no one knows then like you know yeah it's like how you know the game awards they make you apply to co-stream it yeah it's just that so like but you know other people you know they can't catch everyone so a big streamer they can't catch you right right right all right
i'm ready this time i'm excited yeah let's do we can have a doing another quick match yeah we can we can i think we can right i mean we can all just leave afterwards worst case scenario we back out it's fine oh yeah we're already in
i'm still thinking about that team dookie yeah just confirming uh the first match is team doobie oh yeah if you're not playing you know you're you're watching every match okay cool got it okay it's all it's all best of one so it should be okay thank you you got it yeah that's what i thought i was like there's no way they're going to have us do like two at a time because they can only commentate on one at a time so we're just gonna wait did he say we have to watch the um yeah i think yeah well okay we don't have to you could like i can't really put it up on my stream but i'll just watch it because i do have to know what they're playing time to study yeah because we actually i haven't seen any of the teams the other teams besides us i haven't seen any of them play together yeah yeah yeah i like watch some of the replays i like to put on my put on my nerd glasses and was like brought out the expo marker started writing on things you know like there's coaches out there yeah that's the fun
part for me the whistle and everything too i can't wait to drain them dry oh it's not going fast that's not what i said that is i like how we're playing no tanks here i like you guys i like it you're never gonna
don't worry i believe in the no tank play okay i'm gonna go after this movie night real quick inside we're winning it's okay we're winning we're winning we're so scared they're so scared i don't know why i don't know why they're so scared awesome what's that guy doing i need okay i'm gonna anti the backline the entire backline no i'm gonna die first no oh brulow brulow brulow brulow brulow brulow brulow brulow I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh no, you got a tank.
Oh, you got a tank.
Not me.
Oh, tank.
I'll do it.
Oh, you got blue.
You got the blue thing.
What if he's blue?
What if the thing Yeah, what if he was blue?
I might be tanking with you in a second.
I'm gonna die.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm a goaded blue thing.
I'm gonna go.
anti starlord oh my god they're invisible it's fine it's fine i almost have they wasted they wasted they wasted yeah yeah exactly i think they have i don't know here for sure i'm not all checked i'm coming this is quickly thank you okay can we shoot that um i'm not oh nice nice we shot it we actually shot it i'm so proud of you guys i'm healing yeah i cleansed it i still died
That guy.
Urm.
Score girl, heal me please.
You can copy and support.
I don't know what you want.
I didn't realize you were.
I love it.
Peace and love.
I don't know how to heal you.
Sage, revive me.
We're out of here.
All right.
I got to go here.
I gave you damage, Dug.
All right.
It's okay.
I go in with my, are you guys ready?
Okay.
Yeah, you okay.
Okay, he can.
All right.
Here, I'm in.
Someone didn't get it because he wasn't in.
Oh, my God.
You might need to assemble to us.
We're literally a support.
Right here.
My bad.
I kind of assembled by myself.
Yeah, I was going to say, I was like, where's my kill from my Captain America?
We got point.
I have copy.
Yeah, use it on me.
I thought I was playing Marvel.
Sure.
Oh, you got break.
I broke that wall down.
And B, I'm gonna I'm gonna switch.
That's a nice copy.
Yeah, nice good copy.
Outside group.
That's the boost I needed.
Moon Knight wants money.
I'm scared.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Thank you, user.
What the fuck?
Yo, Phoenix just solo alted.
He didn't want I'm gonna die.
We got this guys in this, this is our match right now for those who are watching.
This is- Gonna have to play X-Men and teams for the one to win it all.
This is- yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in the finals right now, everyone.
I got a- So short breath right now.
I do Grooter in the building, I can't stop myself.
I can't stop Grooting!
I'm gonna Groot!
Oh my- I love Groot.
Oh my- Oh my- Oh my-
I was like, you got knocked out round one.
Yeah, they were just stronger than us, man.
Yeah, yeah, we're just chilling.
We got knocked out, but we're just chilling now.
Look at my, look at my squirrel.
Look at how cute he is.
He's got a little blue backpack.
Oh, is he really?
Oh my God, he does.
What's he got in there?
That's so cute.
I'm not.
Go top, right?
Oh, right.
Okay.
Hey, here, go here.
I'm gonna try and ante someone.
Okay.
Oh.
All right, guys.
I can fight here.
I'm gonna anti on the right.
I'm not.
Oh, I missed.
They have an ultram, by the way.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
All right.
I'm playing for today.
I don't have cards.
It's okay.
Oh my God.
She's lost.
Lost like a fish.
Where are you going?
Do you know where you're looking?
Can we get point?
Can we move point?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're coming over here.
There's a flyer.
Here, I got you.
I'm well here.
We claim it.
Give me the ultron.
I want him.
Nice.
Give me him.
I am.
That's a little bit too much.
Too much.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting too excited.
Too excited.
Hey, I didn't pay zero dollars to not push a button.
You guys let out too much of your load, guys.
Too much.
I'll get it back so quick.
Not me.
I saved it.
I'm okay I'm okay I forgot I can't crouch in this game go up go up and go up and go up I told you I play Fortnite when I'm playing group holy shit you weren't lying oh I got somebody back there anti-group anti-group he's stuck on the wall he didn't see it coming I stole the Alton Gambit because he's stupid and I hate his cards.
He's dead.
Good job.
Die!
Yeah, I got a little...
Hey, little girl.
It's okay.
If you want to go have fun, you can get off my back.
Go ahead.
I'll be here.
He's one.
I'll be chilling.
Dad, dad, dad, dad, dad, dad.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I don't have cleanse here, so if you get Groot Alton, you're fucked.
Oh, hell yeah.
This is a free ultimate down this hallway.
Okay, good.
Nice.
All right.
Groot's alone.
The box is in.
The box is good.
Nice.
Watch on.
There he goes.
I got rebuilt around myself.
I'm going to use my, we used my gambit first.
And then we'll copy later.
We'll copy.
Oh, wait.
What's this guy?
What are you doing here?
Hey, get off of her.
Leave her alone.
What are you doing here?
Is this guy bothering you, princess?
Oh my god, this guy's bothering you.
I got you.
I'm low, I'm low.
Thank you.
I heard the death ult.
I'm scared.
Extermination.
You can all for this?
I got two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, this?
Nice.
This last fight anyway.
I don't think they're going to portal in quickly, guys.
You don't know.
You never know.
Sometimes I do it.
I wanted to be there.
Guys, wait for me.
Don't end without me.
Please don't end without me.
Well, I'm starting in 10 seconds.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, but aren't you doing an interview first?
So, no, Machas aren't starting right away unless you guys want to watch at the beginning.
God, Gambit's so cool.
God, he is.
He's so cool.
They're going to nerf him next season.
There's no way.
Oh, no.
No way.
He survives this one.
No.
Like, the current top 500 is, like, majority Gambit layers it's really that makes sense it's so dumb that's crazy what why is he so cool it's because he has a very loving wife and he's like a house husband have you seen the picture of her grabbing the back of his jacket and like dragging him off and it just is manhandled there's one you know like the motorcycle thing like she's actually like he's like the the little spoon in them on the motorcycle oh of course he is yeah and rose the one driving the motorcycle that's crazy I need that.
He has his own dummy mommy.
Like he's living the life.
Can I heal this time?
Yeah.
Actually, yo, yo healers go GPS.
So this is important.
Who are the good healers?
All right.
I got this.
I got this first time gaming.
No problem.
Oh, you got it.
Am I the okay?
We have two healers.
All right.
We got this.
I mean, you guys can run triple Subway.
We can always go three.
Yeah, yeah, that's the plan.
I can just go all healers.
Let me just go ahead.
Let me just hit F1 real quick.
Okay, let's see.
Each card detonates.
It either heals or does damage.
Okay, okay, that's simple.
I can shield myself now.
This is like life changing.
Whoa.
Race.
Okay, that's a big heal for everybody.
Oh, and it's a chain heal.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sometimes I wish we could go back.
Got me a chunk of Cronovium that says we can't.
Oh, yeah, I'm going Loki.
Oh, okay.
Three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
All right,
here we go.
Oh, quickly, it's so easier than screaming, guys.
I'm like, scared for my life every two seconds yeah how'd my team go they're around oh so i i'm dying um okay um that's not our fault we're the dps i'm trying i'm sorry i haven't been i haven't been playing healer i haven't been playing healer all weekend i don't go here yeah i am lagging guys
how i know right where are they healing i want it to be known i never speak to you like this yeah oh there's heals yeah how are we how are we gonna get enabled if our supports are not healing us oh i'm healing you guys trust me just look at the numbers i think it's like six or seven healing i get it no i get it now all right oh my god i'm thinking like i'm playing gambit right now i've been playing him so much i got there oh my god i got they're down two they're down three actually i can't see anything you know what i can't see it come here that's right i don't care i don't care we got the point i can do this gamut's not hard no such thing as a hard character yeah just a skilled issue yeah exactly wait what happened to you Not her,
though.
Triple DBS.
Oh my god, I'm so used to like, I'm so used to gambit aimed.
I don't know how to play.
Side lock anymore.
Oh, please break the squirrels.
Hello, Invis.
Hello.
Heavenly, I got you.
I got you.
Oh!
I don't got you in the back line.
I'm sorry.
Oh, they have a magic now.
This deserves your attention.
There we go.
You got it.
Nice tool.
Look at that.
Now that our support started healing again.
Okay.
I just cracked 2K healing.
I'm a little proud of myself.
Now you know how we feel.
I don't talk to you guys like this.
I'm at 2K.
What you rocking with?
Let me know.
I'm giving you the rank experience.
Oh, I might need to catch up.
Oh.
Thank you guys.
I'm so scared.
I'm dead.
What the fuck?
Nice.
I'm going for the fantastic.
There you go.
There's a squirrel up there!
She's assaulting me!
Me looking at a tree.
I'm at a public park.
I'm back here.
I'm not done killing you.
Whoa.
I'm gonna make a name on myself.
I'm about to make a name for myself here.
I'm about to make a name for myself in this place.
Oh, don't be waiting for this.
Oh, shit.
You don't know how long I've been waiting for this.
Oh, don't I've been waiting for this.
Wait, guys, there's a magic in it right behind us.
You guys are just getting backshotted by a magic.
I think that was a little bit excessive.
Uh-oh.
Um...
We're doing it.
I thought that was the second round.
I popped all.
Oh, well, it's okay.
You're MVP, so, like, you could do whatever you want.
Okay, thanks, guys.
I'm never mean to my healers, because I started playing healer, and I don't like yelling at them.
That's crazy.
I feel like I'm just training your mental.
I'm training your mental.
I never say that to people.
Training your mental is insane.
Oh, my God.
I'm making sure you'll live past the ring.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You think what I say is bad?
Get ready to get to plat.
Okay, ma'am.
Yes, ma'am.
And then it gets worse.
The higher the rank, the worse the...
No, I actually feel like ever since I got...
Like, ever since I started playing a diamond, like, it's, like, a lot better.
The people were worse in silver.
No, no, no, no.
The worst I had was when I started diamond.
That was where everyone just had mics and would not learn how to both shut up and not say bad words.
The higher I've gotten, the more people are, like...
like actually like willing to play the game i like silver a lot because there would just be people like talking to their parents in the background hello goodbye guys my frames are dropping it feels like oh no this map is this map is known as the worst map for frames oh guys guys yes there's three different ones on us freaking magic oh come here hello Oh,
hey, there's captain too.
Where?
Oh, cool.
Watch out.
Wait, okay.
And Silver, can they give you the gamer words?
Um, yeah.
Oh, okay.
It's just the same then.
Yeah, it's the same.
Yeah.
I mean, there are many.
Whoa, I'm gonna...
We're missing a healer back out there.
back out please there's also they have strange out too so good luck i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry where are your heels i don't know we're dead i died i'm scared we don't have to say it anymore she just says it herself we've trained her well that's right support apologize it's never it's always your fault remember that Ever since we were playing A-R-M,
every time I don't heal her, she hits me.
God.
As she should.
Oh, we're supposed to go see the other one.
Wait, cap, cap, cap.
You are on a solo adventure.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I like that.
And then I hit shift and a right click again.
Oh, I'm free.
Oh, my God.
And then I hit Q.
There's a man.
He loves America.
Please help me.
am nearly i'm nearly shooting here as much as i can um yeah you're yeah no i can't i can't save that i'm gonna play i have my alt for the next push we go you do i do oh i can do this i have i have art you have all let's go
They used Inviscerity.
And then I hit it again, and then it does the heal.
Oh!
Okay, but don't get blown up, though.
I thought he was just counting the...
I'm just...
What the hell?
Extermination.
Where am I?
Get down from there.
I've been asking myself for it.
What?
I've been asking myself that for a long time.
Oh!
Hey, I'm not gonna lie.
I just really don't feel...
I don't really feel that safe here.
I'm not even gonna lie.
Oh my god, it sucks because their supports are healing their teammates, but I don't know what that feels like.
Oh my god, the shade is insane.
That's true, you don't, because you died too fast for me to heal you.
Heal step back a little bit, come on.
Oh, you guys are in there.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I am so scared.
There is a heal.
Where is my damage?
Oh my god, the DPS has healed.
I don't know.
I'm so scared.
Guys, I'm so scared.
There's a man.
Respawn faster.
I don't understand.
I'm alive.
I got a triple kill.
I'm ace.
I can see whatever I want because I'm ace.
That's true.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
My bad.
Holy shit.
I swapped to cloak and dagger because I have a hard time keeping track of you, Yuzu.
You're so high.
Oh, yeah.
When you first storm, you just gotta play like Luna or cloak and dagger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm definitely trying to stay a bit lower.
They're pointing forward.
Yeah, no, no.
You do not want to stay lower.
No, go higher.
Oh, they're the top.
Go to the top.
They're the top.
They're there.
I can- I can cloak this.
Cloaking.
You- you, uh, yeah.
A-ah, a-ah.
That's crazy.
But I'm alive.
Yo, the sun's in my eyes at 9 o'clock at night.
I swear.
I was alive.
But I was alive.
What happened?
I think I think I was legitimately just a little bit too far from it.
No, I left clicked.
I just stopped begging to hit you in the front of the car.
Oh, well then, oh.
Wait, was that my fault?
Why didn't you stop me from left clicking?
Yeah, honestly true.
My bad.
That could have been avoided.
It's okay.
All sports after the first time.
Somebody draw her just kicking us.
We're, me and heaven.
just gonna kick all the all the support players just kicking us holy insane now you know the pain also what the fuck is involved on support he's got deals he's got experience the same thing what do you mean now they're gonna kick you too now they're gonna kick you too forget about you what did i do okay fine i'm playing my favorite healer i'm playing my favorite healer there we go
Don't worry, I have experience healing.
How can we die if we're running triple support?
I have two games of experience in healing.
I got this.
I just, I'm out of practice.
I've been doing something else for a while.
Bubble in that corner.
I'm going to get high ground.
You're with me.
I'm trying.
I'm really trying.
holding right click as hard as i can if i landed on you guys blend them you zoo blend them you zoo oh my god who is so low don't worry i also have a look watch out watch out i got your heavenly oh wait they're over here oh my god i feel so good there you go behind behind behind spell it which i got her i got her look at that guys we're doing i'm gonna make a name for myself here what is that is that an emote Yeah,
I was chatting Tatum when he's playing Gambit.
Yeah.
It was like, yeah, like a five minute cameo and that's all everyone remembers it because of it.
Fucking Deadpool, bro.
It's so awesome.
Oh, this does heal you guys.
I don't know how long I've been waiting for this.
I probably should have been spamming that more often than.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh, he's up.
Oh, no.
Where's our res?
Oh, there it is.
I got there.
I don't have res.
I need her.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm holding.
I'm holding this.
You know, it's fine.
It's okay.
We still got point.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I can't quote this.
Did she do it?
Oh, she did it.
Oh, my God.
She did it too.
I did it the fatherly true.
My fucking god.
I'm just saying you did it again.
She did it again.
I was on your side.
What are you fighting with me?
Oh.
That's so awesome.
She's just trying to be supportive, man.
I can't aim.
We get strange.
It's okay.
Me too.
I'm so used to a gambit aim that I'm having trouble adjusting.
Watch out!
Oh my god!
Oh!
We gotta shoot that.
We did a gambit first.
I'm sorry.
I was only holding right click.
I have my ult and I'm so red.
just just get him just get him out of the second they show let's go nice well i've got him too with you i've got him believe i i'm trying to protect you it's okay i'll today i'll today yes is odd me but what is wrong what is wrong with you please please oh my god he's on you so bad he is on you so wait cap is one cap is one oh beautiful no come here no matter of fact i'm gonna come in this guy and get you yeah kill him kill him kill him oh my god that was incredible i don't know that was crazy we didn't know that we won that i think we might win with this we should take this yeah we should yeah just swap everything we learned to see that for sure for sure they're all everything we've strategized for so it's like is that a bot lobby for no it's quick play guys like some there's actual like no they're just babies yeah yeah
okay let's i guess now we can are you playing now uh they should have started right yeah they should have started right technically i'm gonna check it out chat are they are they did they start it uh they're still talking oh they're still talking okay okay all right When did they start?
Promptly at 4.
I think that's what I said, right now.
They're still starting.
Or I guess we can play another?
Or do we not risk it?
Hello.
Where is our...
Where is our king?
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
Sorry, one second.
Okay, okay.
So that we can...
I see the co-stream thing on Iron Mouse's channel.
So we all have to open up the co-stream?
I guess because it links the mainstream.
If you click the co-streaming thing.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, our game is the second one after this because they're streaming it.
Yeah, my chat's asking about it.
They're streaming it like back to back.
They're not streaming it simultaneously.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, from these quick play games, I'm going to play way too impressive on Gambit.
Join Coastream?
These quick play games, they're very risky because competitive Gambit is so different from Quick Play Gambit because I know I'm better than like cross players, so I'm doing the dumb shit.
I am now co-streaming with them also.
I am also co-streaming, but I don't know what it Oh, it just makes it so that when you click on you click on your channel, it links them directly to what stream you're watching.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
So they're like, Oh, what are they watching?
You're like, oh, it's Seedog's channel.
Oh, it shows them with like everyone.
Yeah.
Because they're like, oh, this is the main broadcast.
Oh, they're starting.
They're starting.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to check.
We watch.
Yeah, I'm watching.
The main broadcast doesn't have it yet because I assume there's a delay, but they're showing what they're playing.
So if I go to her and then hit the button.
Do we just watch her?
I'm just watching what the comps are playing.
Oh, co-streaming.
Oh.
How does this work?
How do we get in this?
Start coaching.
You just click it.
I don't see it.
Oh, that thing.
This thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm watching.
Hmm.
Does it show it on our streams or how does this work?
Yeah.
Chad, do y'all see it?
No, I think it just says who's in the stream.
I mean, there is sign.
Oh, so then I still got to pull it out and put an OBS.
I'm showing the teams now.
Okay.
I just want to make sure because I didn't want it to like double up.
They are doing.
Yeah, for sure.
For sure.
running okay i'm gonna look at my notes too as well i don't know they're actually running triple support sorry maybe the side last minute is that a hawk eye i see yeah they swap oh yeah they're running oh never mind yeah you're right i knew they're gonna that's the thing they're gonna run hell and the more they don't get siloed but is that hell in the more map i don't know oh wait i wait i do know i have the i have the cheat sheet the cheat sheet it is that's not that's not an actual hell in the more map the
doobster someone's like siloed bad and big season for it bro these guys do not know how fucking broken silo she's so scary i felt so i felt so bad because I saw Duby kept asking to run scrims, and we were, like, busy, and I was like, I felt really bad.
I wanted to.
Yeah.
I think, like, scrims, you don't...
Or maybe she's trying to get intel.
Yeah, the thing is, normally, people don't scrim with the people within the tournament, because, like, you know, the intel.
So, like, in pro-play, any teams just scrim EU teams.
So they don't, like, leak the intel.
Oh, that's interesting.
Or they scrim teams against, like, teams that didn't qualify, basically.
i've uh i've learned a lot just uh experiencing like scrim stuff i've never done stuff like this it's kind of cool it's really cool it's a very foreign world to to me i've not played pro esports esports is awesome when you do fgc because it's not even esports it's you and like 10 dudes in a bar playing
do you remember the one year of um twitch con in vegas where we went to that bar and the bar had caught on the on the big tvs oh what i must have missed that no you were there you got me a drink at that party i'm gonna tell you that i'm gonna tell that everyone should know i was not there at twitch.com no no no i was physically i was yeah no i guess it's vegas and every shot was like seven bucks no bro i woke up and just damn yeah no thank god there's pre-gaming and then there's like pre-warfare and he was he was deep in the trenches both of them are running it hella no more oh my god and then i had the world's worst hangover for crazy yeah i say we've been well i hella for me is more of an issue than no more is yeah but we can't we can't yeah we don't we don't have we don't have the space for it yeah that's why it sucks that it's killing so hard i know it's just running everyone over that's what I'm saying yeah they need to they need to POV SK right now I need to see because because
like if you focus SK their team can still just hit you that's the problem it's not like everyone else doesn't know how to play she plays every hero at a high level focus her either because well Yan's gonna beat you in the back of the head also it's just not enough bands if it was like if it was uh MR um I guess like the tournament bands then you can because there's enough bands because you get three bands in tournament play but it's but we don't get three bands like we need we actually need three bands but we don't get three bands but i think if they went turn advanced versus because i know they're like oh but we want them to have oh she's not missing we want them to have fun but like um there's just so many characters there's too many characters to have like ring bands in a competitive environment
limited hero pool yeah yeah blur stop fighting and run gang what are you doing oh god the sk flank yeah that's what you guys have to be aware of the thing is you have to be aware of too like she will do that because every good neighbor player will be so loud okay watching us if we can non-stop yeah if we can we need to just keep our comms like as clear as possible so we can hear she is just mark it for me i will anti her and then like we just got killer instantly like we have to just get a turn on her yeah because like drink some water if you haven't don't get dehydrated and get a headache hey no i think amelie's team is very strong they are just because they have just because like sk itself is like a hard carry i think that's insane on um dubie's team who is the one we have to watch out for Dubee's team,
I would just say is Blur.
Blur.
Blur is a...
Blur is a FPS all-rounder.
He's on everything.
Yeah, and also he used to be a top 500.
I mean, he still is.
He's Predator, top 500 Apex.
And he's always been consistently high rank.
Okay.
So, like, you know, it has the FPS.
The thing is, the good thing about Triple Support is that it tilts DPS players.
because it's so hard to kill.
But Helena Moore allows the Namur to basically try and kill one of the supports that we just have.
Also, are they lagging?
Do you see her pain?
Yeah, yeah.
They're lagging.
The packet loss, man.
Are they...
Are...
It's like...
Are their POVs lagging too, or is just the spectator?
I'm not sure.
I think it's the POVs.
Yeah, I don't...
I don't have the...
It's...
We've been having...
We've been...
The Cloudflare...
like down thing has been really impacting like our practices and stuff as well yeah
oh they're lagging too they should pause it pause the game if they're lagging too do they know that that's a thing you can do eski knows it i don't she she knows that you can pause it so
they should just she might not need it i'm genuinely scared of sk like yeah That's why we have to get sidewalk out.
Dude, she's going to clip farm us.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's fine.
The thing is, we just get rid of, we, as soon as we turn, like if she flanks, she's fucked, because we all just turn on her.
As long as we all turn on her, we're fine.
And then also, she can lose.
If she has a health bar, it can hit zero.
Yeah.
Like, all we have to do is just turn on her.
It's not humanly possible.
Well, she's built different, so so are we so scary the power of friendship listen you might not be able to out mechanic her but you can out skill her with your team yeah because it's a team game yeah it's a power of friendship it's okay we have these track to make it a 5v6 remember that guys right we have we can make it a 5v6 easily okay okay uh dubious dubious team banned hawkeye and uh siloac and then yeah i don't know chef i think they've been siloed to target they tried to target as k yeah it's not worth it she's gonna play something else and whoop your ass anyways no no no silo bed is worth it it is no no yes i understand that but the hawkeye i don't understand why they banned hawkeye because they know that heavenly's here yeah that was that was for me oh my god the solo ulti was insane but look look right now she's throwing everything she's got at them no one has died on enemy team Yeah,
because triple support is literally triple support.
Yeah, but as I'm saying, you can still out.
Hunter's her skin.
Also, yeah.
I'm going to type something in chat that like type something in chat real quick.
Where's the thing?
There's so much apps on screen.
So much apps.
I really like this skin, actually.
It's purple noises.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, y'all got to make that breakable.
Yeah, yeah, you see.
That's got to be.
That was heartbreaking to see just now.
Like, look at the what I typed in chat.
OK, give me a second.
Yeah, so this falls apart.
I was watching this game in 480.
Their comp instantly falls apart if we just see that.
Nauru Hodo.
Watashiwa.
Okay, Blur, let's see it.
Come on, just one, just one, just one.
We're about to see it.
There's another.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Come on, Blur, one more.
Holy shit.
Oh, oh, again?
He just needs, he got two supports.
He got two supports, a third.
Somebody stop him.
And that's overtime.
Oh, my God.
That's my boy.
If, when, when if they run Bucky, we have to swap off Loki.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's one.
That's great.
invis yeah you guys have to swap between the two i can film okay cam i will be right back yeah all good um oh my gosh not to add a delay for your upcoming match surprise sk didn't swap bucky i just think sk is just really strong on the more right now with not the yeah with the hella because she's really strong with the hella and then i also just think she's such a like all-rounder capable player like she's very confident her team up enables sk with that added anti-heal like she could just burst anyone she wants yeah
and they're like make sure to go to the bathroom before you're before we start your game yeah i'm gonna use the restroom my favorite back guys oh it's almost over it's almost our turn no they have They have to do this.
Yeah, it's only one more round.
One more round is like maybe 10 minutes.
I'm going to pee.
That's not good.
Yeah, no, no, no, no.
Go ahead.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
That wasn't for you.
I was just, I thought it was going to go longer.
All right.
I'm just looking up what we have to ban here.
Oh, we're going to show this team here.
I think, I think we just, I think we just let you ban and like, uh, not complicate it with.
Yeah, yeah.
I just need to make sure that we're not on an Angela map.
Yeah, let me see what they're playing on attack defense.
Yep, they're doing Naimore again.
Damn.
Bucky Punisher.
Blur is nasty.
See the score, no?
Yeah, it's just a, like, you know, like, it's just a shooter.
Yeah.
It's like...
The score's at the top.
It's zero and two right now.
Or you mean, like, the scoreboard?
Yeah.
No.
Man.
Like, Blur knows.
The moment, he just needs to target Yanners.
He's like, he's confident that he is a better player than Yanners because he's been playing FPS for his entire life.
Yeah.
And then the moment, you know, you got, they got a pick and then it's just over.
I played Apex against him once he ran my shit and I was like, alright, I get it.
I get it, man.
That's crazy.
Some of you are just built differently.
I hope we're not the back-to-back match.
I hope one of us has to be the back-to-back match Yeah, what does that mean?
It means like after our game, we have to play another game with someone Oh my god, but it's either us or Chido that has to do it That's the thing, so I hope He's nasty, did you see that shit?
Yeah, oh my god What happened did blur like he just got a penta Yeah, that's just bucky up That's why like if we know they have a bucky up out for it.
We can't like, we gotta like hold it.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, we gotta coordinate the supportals.
We need to know you guys should figure out who's going first and who's holding.
Okay, okay.
I need to look at my... Alright.
Oh yeah, I need to copy my notes here.
So whenever we need to ban Hella Nemore and whenever we need to ban Angela.
Actually, yeah.
I don't know if I should waste a ban on Angela, but Groot.
We'll see.
It depends on the map.
Uh-uh.
I am Groot.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, you're doing it again.
Oh, it's so nasty.
Wait, I think I literally...
I hate it so much.
I think just don't have a support ult for it.
They literally don't.
They're running all...
They had a dubby ult for it.
They had a cloak and dagger, but I think she might be dead.
no no i meant um i meant the blur's all they literally don't have like they just don't save alts for uh bucky oh yeah i'm not closing it either almost team is just an invis and uh and a gambit yeah they ran double sub they didn't run triple support if they ran triple support i think like yeah they could have held yeah no yeah full full respect blur is insane he's just correct oh for sure yeah this is actually crazy i thought like i don't know honestly thought that SK's team was going to win this so this is very putting up a very significant fight but I just blur yeah he really locked in at the last second holy shit I'm back oh my god what did I say gang what did I say even gods can bleed they can bleed I told you should never get to your head you know what you're that's the case we change our bands then okay the thing is do you want to okay i'll type it i'll type it here okay okay
learn lock the heck in it was so scary i i can't wait so i can beat blur's ass myself
do we know who we okay
uh make sure you don't show the password for the room oh okay i'm uh okay how do we get into this also also also her losing might filter how do we get into this how do we get into this room um you have to look instructions in the discord yeah i've swapped scenes too or not swapped scenes i hide where are you leave leave the lobby if you leave my lobby you can go in You can find it.
The instructions are...
Yeah, you leave the lobby and then you'll be able to find the room.
Custom game?
Yeah, yeah.
Custom game and then type the map name.
The name.
Let me close that.
Okay.
What?
They haven't made it yet.
I don't see it.
Yeah.
I don't see it yet.
They have like...
You and I troll?
Yeah.
You and I die.
Oh, wait, I'm in it.
Oh, you're in it?
You invite us?
Oh, I see it.
I don't see it.
I can't see it.
It's in tournament room.
Oh, okay.
I was in casual room.
I invited just everyone.
But I don't have a heavenly.
I invite.
I invite it.
I invited.
Okay, I'm going to check the map what they're playing on.
Can I show this lobby or no?
Yeah, you can.
You can.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I hope I definitely hope that didn't just DQ us.
but i went into bruce chat like that's my boy well we're not we didn't play against him it should be a five yeah i guess it should be five let me okay oh god all right damn isa's like that what okay isa are we missing i don't go here i don't go here let me out how do i leave how do i join the and then wait for wait for them to swap and then yeah yeah yeah okay well she's not swapping okay now and then click it and it could join on do
you guys listen to music while you play or do you play in silence i would be listening i know i can't balance i can't No, I don't.
Not me.
I need to focus.
Yeah.
I used to, but not.
I listen to MR Music.
I am ready.
What is that?
The MR Bible is music.
Oh.
I like, feel like I look, you need it.
I need to enter my flow state.
Because like I can.
It's just, I gotta, actually, I might, hold on.
You know what?
No, because listening to music makes me stupid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
You're right.
then the beat drops and it's like i gotta all i gotta kill somebody now okay that's not an angela map do you think you want to be today okay so make way for the king of t's do your usual we'll do we'll do iron fist comp got it got it okay and then i banned bucky
Just let Doki ban so we don't mess with her.
Oh, it's not doing the thing where...
We are escorting.
So this is...
Do you guys want to ban Sylock or Penny?
Um...
I feel like Penny is a pretty good at holding.
So maybe...
Yeah, this is a...
It's like a convoy to...
They took your...
They took Gambit.
That's fine.
Then we have our...
So what are we running?
We're running Mr. Fantastic.
Uh...
You want Penny?
penny then yeah can someone press penny for me i got it um if we're running mr fantastic do you want me to play tank you want me to play dps what do we do what do we do okay it is magneto emma uh fantastic and then i bought a skin for this they fell for it they fell for it
Life energy is a powerful weapon.
So Loki, Mantis, and then who was the third supporter?
It was either Invis or Luna.
Okay.
Can you hear us now?
Yeah, I can, but...
Yeah, I like that.
I think Invis is better though, isn't it?
I mean, Balila can't hear us or something.
Oh, it can.
Okay, I can request pause.
Oh.
RTC connecting.
Pause, please.
for our team.
We can't change the server someone, one of the admins would have to.
I would just reload this screen.
I can't initiate pause.
Pause, please.
I'll do like...
I'll do at...
Can you at?
Okay.
At Alex.
Pause.
We don't have this.
squared.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
Danka.
Of course, Discord fails on our friend saying is they're saying restart Discord.
Oh, wait.
We have several players that can't they can't list here.
Okay.
Oh, even on Shoto's team?
No, for us.
We have several?
Okay, I put...
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Is everyone okay?
Yeah, I'm here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How about kick you?
I'm here, I'm here.
Okay, we're good.
All right.
Let's just do our...
Yeah, let's test manager close it.
All right.
Okay, okay.
Do you want Emma or...
Is it Emma or...
Mag Emma?
We do Mag Emma.
Okay, got it, got it, got it.
Ready?
Oh, thank God they don't give me the other button.
Oh, my God.
Let's get the shit out of me when I did that.
Okay, yeah.
I got a new skin.
Check it out.
Nice.
That's tough, twin.
Thank you, twin.
It's tough, twin.
You look good, twin.
Damn.
Okay.
Thanks, ladies.
You had a 5% all charge, idiot.
They're playing really deep.
There's a name more in the back.
We got some range to hit those squids because I can't.
Okay, I got it.
Pushing up.
I have such one.
You bubbled.
Go ahead, get in.
Let's go pushing up.
I'm going to push you.
We can get Mag.
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag.
Mag, Mag, Mag.
Put in pressure on the healer.
Got him, got him.
Nice.
I'm literally just on the healer.
I'm just on the healer.
They're not paying attention.
Oh my god.
I got you.
I'm coming.
They're at the top.
Focus on.
Focus support.
Look at it.
Focus back, focus back.
Got him!
Hold up top.
I'll hold up here.
Hold up here.
Hold up.
She's not going to throw her life away.
Nice kill, nice kill.
Good take.
This auto, this auto pushes.
Push up, push up.
This auto pushes.
So any VPS just get in her face and she starts just fucking like whipping the water.
They auto pushes.
I got you.
Pushing.
I think I'll have a freeze.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Even if you just use it for defensive.
We use mine for aggressive.
Back up.
I'll use what they use.
10 seconds.
I think they switched to Punisher.
There's Punisher now.
They have an Emma now.
Did they always have an Emma?
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
I have all set.
We're going to go in the moment I have a...
Okay.
Got it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, I can't see you.
Okay, hold on.
Don't go bash, go bash, go bash, go bash.
Can I get boost?
Can I get damage boost?
Damage boost, please.
They ate me.
They have a revive beacon.
Where is she taking me?
Girl?
Where are we going?
Toma doesn't know where she's going.
Toma?
Bye, Toma!
Keep aggressive, keep aggressive.
Keep aggressive.
Any heals?
I'm using the front.
Sorry, sorry.
You're fine.
You're fine, you're fine, guys.
I'm hitting the rocket alt.
Rocket alt down.
We have no support up here.
Back up.
Back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up.
Oh, we're going to lose her.
No, they don't know.
They don't know.
I can ult him.
I'm on him.
That's big.
He don't.
I'm so sorry, Toba.
She's so nice.
I got it.
I'm pushing and pushing card.
Just push card.
three on card three on card three on card push that shit in no no it's good push that whole thing in they're not that's fire that's such a fire i don't see a string i told you i'm hiding
the confidence holy okay i'm gonna i'm can build off here my arms are my hands are shaking right now so why are you just stop me too bro i got suck here you guys show back up back up it's fine things push up a little bit we have i got damage for you i'm not here yet one second we're just giving space i have all soon and then the moment i all we go in ready three two one go go go go push up push up push up push up i'm on the punish here i'm also on putisher put i'm going back i'm going back i'm going back i'm going back i'm looking i'm gonna go in viz in viz behind behind behind they're down a healer though they're down a healer coming coming back i'm going back it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine just play play safe we're oh play safe okay oh we're down a healer all about this back up this back it up back it up back it up back this back it up Oh,
she shot me!
Oh, this is again.
Please do not.
Invis.
Spread.
Honestly, I'm gonna punish her.
Okay.
Oh yeah, save punish her.
Oh!
She missed.
Oh, nice.
Oh, he's using.
Use her.
Sorry, sorry.
Cray, go, go, go.
No, Shilu's gotta have all.
Shilu's gotta have all.
Damage, mage.
Yeah, yeah.
Got you.
I got you.
Yeah, mage.
A mag one.
Invis.
dead dead nice nice nice right side jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff come back come back come back pushing back pushing back yeah come back i have invuln i have invuln nice nice oh that's so clean good job oh my god time to switch oh okay nice oh my goodness this is holy ghost all right so this uh we can run the same comp here um i would did they run mag i wasn't paying attention yeah they ran mag okay but lezu's mag he's only looking forward he's not turning around bubbling anybody so okay so because i'm wondering because we could run cloak for this um but it's working on because we do have mr fantastic so i have to stay on uh to stay on mantis here it's fine this is it works as long as it works we can stay here i think this works yeah we got this what is the What am I hearing?
Hambone!
Someone's a little bit...
My hands are like shaking so much.
Yeah, no, me too.
I'm literally, I can't hit anything because my hands are shaking.
It's adrenaline.
Just let it rock.
Let it rock to your body.
Chew, chew, chew.
I took my Adderall today and it's maybe working against me right now.
I'm lucky.
I've passed the flow state.
I've entered the shaking state.
Oh, come back.
down that's insane oh my god i hope we're not next after this game i want chill yeah i want to pee oh just be like oh we can't play next we have to pee we gotta pee we all have to pee no way yeah we all have to pee um that's a crazy right click bro where do i where do i stand here where do i I don't know.
It just felt right to hit that lacing the head with a rock.
Rock.
Let's drop down.
Give me that crystal.
Rock.
Nice, nice, nice, okay.
Nice, nice, good, nice, cool, nice, nice.
There's one down.
I'm pushing up or showdown.
You still play sort of forward.
Not too far.
Don't part this area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Power you can chill a little bit here.
Thank you.
Just give me that crystal.
His walls should be.
Oh my god, I got my...
I pushed his walls up.
Nice.
Nice pull, nice pull.
You're not playing Groot.
Groot.
Let me play Groot.
Back out, back out, back out a little bit.
We can get one.
You pull the man.
Back up, back up.
Cut it out.
Cut it out, back out, back, back, back.
You don't have to be in that.
You don't have to be in it.
Ladies who's pushed up pretty far out.
Watch out for Mantis ult.
I'm all here.
Go, go.
Push, push, push, push, push.
They're down one.
We can just kill them all.
Just kill them all.
We'll push on the healers.
All three healers.
way.
All one healer.
We can back.
We don't have to.
Oh, actually, back out now.
Back out.
Good job.
All right, for this, we can aggress again and you copy me and then we go in again.
We do the same thing.
But if they punish you all, we have to put the, we have to use the... I'll hit Q immediately.
It'll be a double knife.
Invisalty?
I'll, yeah, I'm standing for Punisher.
Or we have Magald.
We have Magald too.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
Copy me whenever.
And then we could push this.
All right.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Do the same thing.
Can I get damage boost, please?
Damage boost, please.
Yeah, yeah.
Damage boost.
We are undefeatable!
You still saying so far?
Start backing up.
One's all.
Emma wants all.
Emma wants all back up.
Start backing up.
You see your bubble?
Yeah, yeah.
She wants all.
Yeah, I just wanted to put a shield down for Lila.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I have Involne.
I have my alt.
Is he holding all?
Is he holding all for me to hold my own?
All right.
There it is.
Hey, I'm kiting.
I'm kiting it.
Anybody caught in it?
No, no, no.
We're all fine.
I'm going to all them on the backside.
Nice, nice.
Help, help, help, help her.
I can't bubble.
Oh, my.
I got two.
I mean, I got Invis.
I got lasers by herself.
They killed me.
Slip her.
Oh no.
I'm my own.
Oh, he's not.
I'm doing last one.
Last one.
Maybe you can't strange.
If you get strange portal.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I almost have all here.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
We have to move up though.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Invis here.
Hit it.
Hit the portal!
Fucking lost them.
We're coming, we're coming.
Hold on.
We're here, we're here, we're here!
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I couldn't get to the invisible woman.
Funny, funny.
I'm gonna go in this rocket.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
That's why, I'm dead.
Oh, the portal.
We're solid as much as we can.
We get still.
We made it.
That's fine.
I'm going back.
Oh, it's all right.
It's all right.
Swap back to your comp.
Swap back off and swap off.
Press G and I have copy.
Just back up fully.
Back up fully.
They're going to start running at us.
And we, like, to our spawn.
We just hold them again.
Yeah, to our spawn.
Back up to your spawn.
Swan.
push us here let's break this wall if you can yeah yeah you can let me know let me know we're not here we're not all here we're not all here just wait just wait we're not pushed up we're not pushed up just i'm here copy me and then we'll aggress again let me know okay copy now copy now copy now you're all here all here you're good copy fuck fuck fuck inside it's okay it's okay we're fine we're fine okay she backed up anyway it's fine i think there's someone to Mantis is above.
Mantis is above.
I got you.
Damage boosting you.
Mag low.
Rizu's almost one.
Can I get another damage boost?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got it, you got it, you got it.
You see you got bubble.
Take it in.
Nice pushback.
Got Shoto.
Mag one.
Nice.
I got it.
Push them.
Push all of them.
There's a, I'm going to try to get this.
Let her go.
Let her play.
No.
Chucky.
I don't have to get back.
We staggered her.
God damn.
I put it out, bro.
Oh, my God.
No.
Kill me.
No survivors.
Not allowed.
This is Marvel rivals.
It's not friendship rivals.
Marvel, bro.
I can't help here.
You made business.
You're Infants?
We got a kite.
Oh, never mind.
Nice.
We got it.
Got it.
No, no.
Here we go.
Hey, show,
go.
I've got the shotgun out of my ass.
I got their troops when I I'm looking at this.
I'm looking at this.
Okay.
I got me.
I got me this.
Rockets in the back.
Tomas low.
Lazy's almost dead.
Lazy is dead.
That's it.
Push them in a spawn.
Back up.
Back up now.
Back up here.
Save him.
Just absolutely back up.
If we can shield this.
You don't want to get caught?
No, we're okay.
We're all okay.
I have copy.
Yeah.
We can use this to aggress this in three.
this okay okay that's nice he doesn't see you he doesn't see you heavenly hey so don't see me just don't see me please yeah yeah oh they're coming to sleep they're focusing me they're so good we're so good everyone is so good oh my god we're not last we can't be last one of many one of many guys we can't be last that's the best part you're right you're right you're right do that feel good seeing your name
on the winner screen yeah oh i'm like i'm nervous i have to pee again oh my god i gotta pee too my hands are shaking oh me too don't worry my hands are shaking too can't be last let's go can we pee now yeah i'm peeing too bathroom breaks everyone bathroom breaks i'm telling you man you do more competitions that adrenaline amazing are we can we use the restroom real quick everybody got up oh you're good dokey are you did you already get up oh no i'm still here okay no bathroom break no no you guys are good uh we're gonna go to i think a quick break uh okay it's gonna be show to anomaly next oh thank god okay and just yeah you're good you're good uh dokey can you join um our mouse and monkey uh main channel right now channel for a second for an interview just real quick Oh,
okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, look at that.
I don't know why that's so funny.
All right, time to go.
All right.
I don't know what to say.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I want to watch the interview.
If you don't want to do it, I'll do this.
No, no, it's fine.
That's my side.
Character she touches is just like insane.
Hello.
Am I supposed to be here now?
I don't know.
Oh, okay.
What was that?
I was very surprised.
I'm very scared and nervous.
No, everyone's hands were shaking during the games.
I mean, if you were shaking, it didn't show at all.
Oh, really?
Okay, I thought my aim was like all over the place there, but I'm very proud of my team.
Everybody's saying he needs to be nerfed.
Oh, my goodness.
No, no, no.
They already took Gambit away from me.
I want to see you play as Gambit so bad.
I was so sad.
god i'm scared correct this gamut i want to see it so bad please don't ban gamut yeah guys please don't ban gamut so i can play gamut she's not that good on yeah exactly i had the least amount practice on gambit so don't ban gamut obviously go going into that game it was a great go what was your kind of team strategy going into that did you have did you study your opponent yeah no we did we actually um i like looked through every team like what they played the last two days and like you know like usually what they're meaning is not actually what they're playing in a competitive environment so i just looked at their matches and be like oh they've been playing this comp they've been playing that comp so or like they only invested all their time playing on this hero so we knew exactly what to ban because like target banning is a strat so like if we get rid of like what they're practicing on the enemy team yeah so uh i know shoto is a bucky player like a good bucky player so um because he
was on my team for the last vtuber rivals and he was a really good Bucky player the last time we were in a team together so I remember that and I was like okay we gotta get Bucky out um so that was basically our strat I also saw that you were you were just running in first you your attention behind you yeah were you just trying to be a good leader what was going on there it's because like when you mantis all like um you get like insane speed boost so literally we're just like Mach 7 into the support backline because like they can't do anything because if you have like a mantis running straight at you what the fuck know so it was like watching a freight train yeah yeah because like my shout was just to go straight to the support like and then kill one of their supports because that's like literally how you play mantis when you all all right well well your next game is going to be against team uh team do you have any uh any any strategies or is it all close to the chest secret you can't
tell us oh i can't yeah no no we can't reveal that yeah we actually have like oh yeah yeah i'm glad we could rest because like we are all like so jittery too so we're like we can calm down for this next game and then go into the next one uh but i know we had like notes and stuff too being like okay this this comp will we have to play this comp and this map will play this comp and stuff like that so oh wow so it's yeah i think this is what's fun for me a little planning going on it's just that's what's fun for me i love competitiveness because i watch esports stuff like i watch pro play like i even went to the land in guanjo so i love competitive in general like i love esports and i love strategizing and stuff so that's what makes it fun for me geoning like I mean it was it was very apparent watching the gameplay it seemed like you're having a great time yeah yeah I'm glad my team is very happy with their first they were so nervous going in so now they're all like adrenaline excitement
everything um they practiced so hard too so I'm just happy that they're going they're just happy we're not last like we can't be last that's what we're so happy about like well thank you thank you yeah thank you again event it's been it's yeah i've been so nervous so but i'm having a blast right now but thank you guys yeah it's gonna go great and thanks for being a part of it i think we all really appreciate you joining that it's fun to see yeah we know i think everyone knows you love this game it's been too much yeah yeah i would do like a street like i'll be playing something else and i would be like let's talk about marvel rivals for 30 minutes before we start the game so so they're used to it fair enough well good luck and uh and have a good rest um and uh yeah i guess you'll watch the game and see what your opponents are up to yeah thank you again thank you i'm so excited all right bye bye guys bye bye oh
my god i'm so i'm like disassociating i did the interview and i was like i'm disassociated now like
I need a...
Well, okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'm gonna join back in VC and then use the bathroom.
Hello, I'm back.
Two teams will be 3-0.
And then the rest of the teams will be whatever's left over.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's like the optimal is two teams at 3-0.
I see, I see.
All right, hello, I'm back.
I'm also... I gotta use the bathroom now.
So I'll be right back.
Okay.
okay how long is the break probably like uh five minutes because the timer just hit four and i looked away for a second oh you know what that means i'm going on tick tock that's the move that's the move bro i respect it it's like being in the gym you know in between sets you got to you got to rest because if you don't rest for sure like you can go back to practice but what are you really going to practice on bots you know let's just i'm just doing breathing to make it gonna keep you so calm i get you oh do we leave the lobby i mean i left i didn't know if i was supposed to or not i just it just felt right okay i'm back y'all ever heard of nerds i'll come back yes i know you're like crazy into nerds it helps in between matches a couple of nerds matches what is dude i got my fidget spinner what is nerds is competitive solitaire is this thing on yeah even know how to play solitaire you just lost me i don't know what solitaire is solitaire is the card game where you got to take the cards
and make sure they it's the stacking one right it's like you put them in like stacks together i don't know how to play that when i played when i played belatro i made it into go fish i was getting doubles never mind yeah i always right now in the spirit i need to i need to calm down my heart is being so fast right now guys so maybe i should i'll be back i'm listening oh my god skins i can buy with my code oh my god i'm so i think i honestly think that new skin that i got just you know it gassed me the hell up i i was talking to my chat before the the game and i was like do i buy this new skin do i buy should i buy this new skin i'm gonna buy it no for real i want the phoenix amma skin but it's gone forever oh is it actually was it from a battle pass yeah sorry you guys i'm like i need to calm down i need to calm down after that my adrenaline was a lot i hate this new namur skin his fingers are disgusting yeah that that i don't know it's horrendous it makes me so scared it looks like
when carrots have gone old and they're kind of wiggly it makes me gag a little bit yeah i don't like it yeah okay buying scarlet witch bundle oh my god blue thing is real wait you're gonna battle pass for free this is awesome what's in the battle pass uh a ton of skins but blue thing specifically you did it great yeah i was so worried to get less so i'm so happy we didn't get last i'm watching the animation with it i was so nervous about getting destroyed because so many people they were all practicing so much i don't even really plan on playing angela but i just want this everyone was practicing the furry one yes so much so i was
good i hope this adam is also really funny i'm just happy i'm so happy no you guys don't understand they got rid of so much everyone was practicing so much like the other no kips they were all they were all playing since morning tonight like and then yesterday we only had our two hours yeah that's all we had as a team together that's all we had and then we had And so I was so nervous.
And it didn't help that I...
Endurance stream battlefield.
It did not help.
Because I was like, okay, I'm going to join.
I'll, like, I'll play with them.
Like, after the...
After the...
The Endurance stream.
Because it's not going to be that long.
But it took so long.
Yeah.
It took so long.
How did...
We screamed against...
a manager team.
So we scrimmed against like people actually who manages all the pro team, like majority of pro teams in rivals.
So they know all the strats and they know all the strats and like what pro players play and how to counter and everything because they have to manage the teams and a lot of them are like decent players too.
So we asked them to play specific cops that we know that other teams are playing.
Do you see round two and round three?
Wait.
um so we asked him to play specific comps that we know what other teams are playing so we could and also doing bands that they might do that us so but then we only had yeah i don't think that was right three hours of that so it was not like we so like that was uh like and then that was like how we strategize the the screen setting um because we're not leaking strats but they can replicate everybody all the captains have fun names to say um huge shout out to to super gomez So,
like, helping out with coaching and giving me, like, ideas on, like, because, like, you know, I don't know everything about pro play, but, like, you know, he does, and he also knows the managers too, so I asked him if he could set up a scrim.
Like, if he could ask the managers, his manager, to set up a scrim for me, and then his manager was like, bro, I could, we'll just do a manager.
Well, bro, you know what?
All us managers, we want to play this game anyway today.
So, like, bro, and then like, all the managers got together and, like, screamed us.
So that's how we did it.
Yeah, and he also, like, helped coach Heavenly.
He gave, like, he gave coaching tips to Heavenly and Bal, too.
So, or Bal, too.
So, like, because, you know, Bal is one of our DPS players.
So, he also coached Heavenly and Bal on, like, what to do.
I coached the support players, and then he did the tank and...
Welcome back.
Oh, he did all the tanks and DPS.
No, no, no, no.
I did a tattoo break.
No, we're watching.
We do not.
Oh, already.
are they starting oh no not starting yeah they've got the lobby ready okay time to see what's up there
oh wait is tooma their new player yeah is that why you guys didn't want me to kill her yeah yeah you put her in the house you tortured her yeah i saw that she's unranked yeah i saw she's why you guys are like don't leave her you can't leave her alone you're like no no survivors no witnesses because we stagger her so they have to wait longer for the entire team to get together dude i know she felt the fear of god in that moment what do i do no mercy who do you who do you guys think will come out on top in this match i'm gonna leave I'm a team 100% I think so too I'm a steamboat place your pickums do a do kill points do Gamba mods can we set up pickums straight through Shoto's team it's messed up because I already saw the Lezu isn't focusing like anything he's just like trying to kill the other tank Lezu is out of position quite a lot yeah they're putting all they're putting all the work on the but you're banning one of the healers is brand new to the game they're all banning bucky did
you see that oh it's because i said it it's because i said the bucky thing and now yeah i said it just put a crazy target i was like yeah so they i made every team target that showed oh now you put a big fat target on his back and said hey kick this guy so insane bro i bet he's molding right now he's actually losing it oh they're wasting a band advantage because nobody on showed us team plays dude he's gonna play yeah i guess they saw what i did on mantis so they're like oh they're about to they're about to feel some you think they're gonna try to implement that when we like fight they're gonna i think you're gonna do well we're not banning gambit that's the thing they have to waste their both bands on gambit and mantis true if you can feel me telepathically talking to you which is strange it will help you a little bit more man just put the wall up stop help stop helping the enemies that's a magneto lock in all right good luck man
the thing is we have like we have like other cops to play it's okay that's that's why we came up with other cops it's like thought about what they would get rid of yeah yeah yeah we probably shouldn't talk about it but we have other comps yeah we're gonna let you get them like if anyone's watching stream we do have other comps that if you plan on snitching no we don't no we so like banning target banning me ain't gonna help you because we have other cops yeah just get in there and have fun guys oh god omeli has the
triple support oh boy no more hella combo oh no it's oh i mean triple support is the strongest comp i guess someone died wait who died oh wait oh wait who are you guys watching uh the mainstream the dokey and connor one wait wait sorry the iron god revived what the fuck mine is like behind okay maybe iron mouse is fast that amma's team has all three of the blonde women yeah one iron okay iron mouse might be like um it's white girl wednesday it's white girl Wednesday.
We rocking Snow Buddy Friday.
Let's go.
Yes.
Oh, God.
Damn, wait.
Yo, Shoto.
Damn.
He's got a he's got something to prove this around.
He's whipping out the no more.
He's locking in.
Yeah.
I love no more.
No more is so fun.
Damn.
I know.
It really feels like...
Go ahead.
I think this was one of the Neymar maps, no?
This is an Angela map.
Also...
Wait, I got another thing for you guys.
Look at chat.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
What?
Yo!
Oh, they...
Never mind.
They swapped for a portal.
Wait.
Chodo's team.
Hey, Chodo's team doing stuff.
They're hella just locked in and started clicking everyone's head.
Kyumi?
Kyumi's executing people.
I see her all over the kill cam.
Yeah, the thing is, like, we are positioning...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, they're running double support.
So she couldn't do anything against us because we were triple.
Like, we were literally...
She, like, hit us and then we just heal each other up instantly.
ask it was insane someone check her computer bro do you remember that clip of the girl who was cheating and sea ice and she's like tell her what did you put on my computer
oh my god uh who put that on my computer oh my god the trash
tracking is insane.
Yeah, it's really interesting watching like really great players.
Let me reload my thoughts.
Who the fuck is Cream Lord?
Is that Aethel?
That's Aethel.
Yeah.
Look, she didn't have mercy.
Oh no!
To my run!
That's so bad.
Oh no.
She was so young.
Look, SK didn't have mercy, so why should I have mercy?
You were first, you said the tone.
Yeah, she watched you do that when I read I'm doing that too.
By example.
That's true.
It is what it is.
Oh.
That was a nasty old.
that was a nasty old he disrupted them a lot he's screaming on him i know he's going at it i'm gonna look at my notes guys he's screaming yeah we're playing dubie's team next right okay yeah they're both they're also on break okay okay i know what to ben okay um that shouldn't be me
i'm i'm theorizing i'm strategizing for a next game oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh they're stabilizing do they have trip support or what no they both were running both of them are running 222 okay i see
Interesting, interesting.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Oh, whoops.
What the fuck is that cross here?
The cogs are turning.
Which one?
The strange?
The strange one?
That's the spread of his bullets for up close.
Oh, what the?
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
yeah it's a really wide crosshair because he's like a shotgun like so if you're really close if you're in that circle you can still shoot and hit him if they're low yeah but that's like that is a weird ass crosshair boy how on earth did sk flank and dare teen die what the happened oh my god this is crazy they probably noticed sk is really she likes to get yank a lot.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, that's what I know.
Like I that's how name more players play.
You can see Shoto doing the same thing where he just walks in the back.
That was a pretty okay.
Oh, oh my God.
Oh, no.
That is just insane.
It's just watching a hydrogen bomb versus baby.
is her first day on the job man oh my god bro hydrogen bomb versus baby is insane
i can't man
actually showed up is doing like their team is doing a great job right now i think when you walked up and said yeah we just banned showed up bucky we just walked away with a you like now you're mad as hell now he's like i know his neighbor is really good he helped us win the rivals with name where too so i didn't mention that i because his neighbor is actually surprisingly really good don't don't piss off shoto yeah like during the v2 arrivals there was a oh there he goes that was crazy damn there he go there he go no during the v2 rivals there was a a pro player sneaked in to this vtuber rivals and then like chodo fucking diffed him like he tried to maggle us and chodo like you know the the the circle title way thing he used this title way thing and blocked the entire maggle oh my god yeah yeah on like with like uh we were like reflex does that does that kill you or are you invulnerable no you're invulnerable you're literally invincible in there so like he literally saved the entire
team by blocking it with with his like the tidal wave he said for my country for my team this is a clincher what oh this shield is nasty oh oh she got him she got him that's game oh look how close to these though oh yeah can they hold can they hold that was right at the edge it was literally at the tip that was so crazy what the heck
yo i think we pissed them off
i take it back it wasn't just you i think that oops
that was nasty i actually like the flow of this this cup a lot it feels like there's a lot of there's up time you know it's not like up up up up up oh i don't oh no no get off the punish there you go bro you're doing so good the boy what you doing bro this is such a good hold for no more that's such a good hold for no more as well yeah this was this is a good oh they're they want to run triple support triple sup they wanted to sustain i i'm surprised they're not running three three then
well there's no mag so i guess this publisher won't be like punished as much like punisher is good on this map too but like his name more was so clean yeah
he's i'm sorry i don't see anyone playing angela i don't know if we should be on here um it's not It was Shoto's team.
It was Shoto's team that had the Angela player.
The team chat in the Discord.
Let me see.
Oh.
It's so cute.
That's cute as hell.
The art is so nice.
What?
I should be the one joining in the stomping.
You're like, I am not a victim.
Yeah, I am not a victim, yeah.
I look like I have a pacifier.
I'm part of the problem.
And she's proud of it.
Yeah!
A problem and proud.
That's right.
I can't believe the cart doesn't block LOS.
It's just not tall enough.
They're just giving up so much space.
They are.
They're scared.
Without losing anybody.
They should push up a bit more.
Like, this is way too much space that they gave up.
No, Strange isn't even on the point.
He's like completely off in Wonderland by himself.
Yo, Shoto, go down mid, man.
Shoto, Shoto, no, I asked to look for flankers.
He's scared.
He's, he's, oh, okay.
Yeah, that's why you don't do that.
Hmm.
What the fuck is, oh, I was going to say, is the, is the mag okay?
Yo, yo.
He took like nine spears to the chin, man.
What the fuck?
Omar, did, did us catch just hit the magnate?
did he just yeah yeah that's how you do it that's so aura oh but shoto is crazy oh the punisher the invid's punisher that's right it's like bad my bucky bad my bucky i sold your girl i sold your earth my bucky oh my god dude he's popping off oh it's hawkeye tab hawkeye is a very good new that's the thing because he punishes hawkeye punishes bad positioning so as long as we don't have bad positioning that's okay look up to the right there's free old charge just standing there no that's the clones you don't get all charged off they were she was up there oh really oh yeah she was just standing there healing it's like oh that's just oh holy game sense don't do it don't challenge her you don't got it like that i mean they're pushing up though for free Oh my gosh,
Shoto, you're fucking wild.
Why are you taking?
Play Gears of War, Shoto.
Let's see it.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Hawkeye's getting altered, though.
He's altered.
SK just wasted it.
No, no.
One kill.
She's got red, too.
He's, no, he doesn't have it.
Yeah, so he's technically zero kills.
Miss, miss, hit, miss, hit, hit.
Oh, my gosh, Shoto, you're fucking crazy for just doing that in front of everyone.
like you bro get high ground shoto get high ground you're crazy they double support oh wait no they didn't okay oh shoto's dead that's insane oh my god caught out no that's the animation that's an easy kill right guys oh point guys point tomah's kind of kiting did you see that she's going left right left right oh tomad's dead oh oh well okay when i said that 10 seconds ago she That's like her tires.
She did.
Oh, they're.
He ends backing out.
No, no.
They don't.
If she is.
Oh, someone's got to save him.
Oh, no.
They can portal.
They can portal this.
Someone's got a portal.
Alma.
What is he?
Oh, my God.
Wait, they full held.
They full held.
Oh.
Wow.
They full held them.
What?
Oh, my God.
Wow.
That's crazy.
What?
I should say.
They literally shut down the Namor.
That's what they need.
Is it our turn?
Wait, is it our turn now?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That's it.
Okay.
Okay, we're all...
Okay, everyone's tied now.
So...
If Amma's 0 and 2, there's no comeback.
No.
No, she's not 0 and 2.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, she is.
Yeah.
Oh, she is.
Does that mean she's out?
no no she has a chance to oh wait yeah she's out are you sure she's one what she's out yeah wow oh my god she i thought she was the favorite because her team was was good yeah with eska yeah because blur won the first one against them yeah yeah yes she's out but she still has like one And y'all were terrified.
I am!
I respect SK's skill!
I respect SK's mechanically crazy.
I know you were, but some people in here had tears in their eyes at the thought of going Okay, okay.
Who is some people had tears?
Okay.
Let me just look at the bends again real quick.
Okay, I got the bends.
okay okay all right is it our turn now yeah yeah so they sent the they sent i swapped i'm swapping the bands a little bit okay all right i got a hard mob game too oh yeah just invite us one person can join and invite the rest of us oh yes invite julian will you please invite me so all right
a dokeybird isa why does this keep happening to me you're on the wrong team wait doobies up there yeah doobies up there doobies on the wrong team for her own for her own team she's swapping guys I'll coach you okay thank you oh my god thank you coach thank you
oh man well we do we know what we're doing for this one yeah yeah I got the bands Wait, why is my okay?
I was gonna say my game wasn't showing up on my OBS.
I got scared.
I don't know if I can kill Blur.
You gotta for country and for team.
For team and for country.
I killed Toma.
If I could kill Toma, you could kill Blur.
You killed Toma because you like stepping on babies.
You're just like, yeah, I love beating up babies and stepping on ants.
And what's wrong with that?
What's wrong with that?
Ain't nothing wrong with that.
I killed Paul, but you a couple of times.
Yeah, exactly.
You're proud of the problem.
But this is my boy.
I don't know if I can.
Bro, he won't hesitate.
Just remember, he won't hesitate to do the same thing to you.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
I'm ready.
All right, I got the bands figured out.
Bye.
I'm sorry I'm I'm I'm just I'm interested what they're gonna ban if they're gonna target bad me music off because it frees up our other comps without without ban yeah I think they're going after you yeah but it does free up our other comps so I don't care about that
all right he's not my boy no more oh oh oh so the match is over Yeah, man.
There's money on the line.
He put the mask on.
I like him, but shit.
That's valid.
That's so valid.
I feel you.
Cut all ties for this attorney.
He's cut throat.
Yeah, you gotta switch them on day ones once you get $5.
We're waiting for a production person for Spectator.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
We have three Spectators.
We're missing.
They said they were waiting on another one.
There he is.
the asian what a name wait that's awesome he asian and proud yes we have to get more asian asians rise up yeah okay let's do it all right why don't we just don't pick anything or we'll pick one thing it's all picked jeff oh yeah let's all pick jeff that's our anyone that's stream sniping us That's one of our god comps.
Yeah, yeah.
All five of us, one character.
No, all six of us is Jeff.
Oh, six.
Six.
Six Jeff.
Yeah, they can't kill us all.
We have insane.
All right.
Yum, yum, yum.
Um.
Okay.
I love.
He's so cute.
I know he's evil, but he's so cute.
No, snap his neck.
He's built like a bulldog.
Throw him into the ditch.
Oh.
She felt like a little bulldog.
I got pumpkin on my head.
Interesting.
That was... that was hateful.
That's a crime.
Are you just batting all supports?
They may have been gambling, yeah.
Maybe they're trying to make a triple...
Maybe they're trying to make a triple heal comp difficult.
Yeah.
an iron fist i'm gonna lose my mind no you're literally a jasmine oh okay easy all right nice all right i can't stop brooding to win this one and then what do you what do you want i think one play either luna luna or cloak you can we can run cloak because they don't have mag nothing can kill you okay okay uh emma or strange what do you guys prefer or or we run luna and then you can our iron fist can never die
we do the same we do the same tank uh tank lineup but instead of mag he's on group okay no no isa needs me isa what were you running emma strange stranger emma uh emma okay okay so put the snowflake on our iron fist only that's it that's all you have to do They may run Angela now.
All right.
Just put it on our iron fist, and then he'll never...
theoretically, you should never die.
So if you die, like, there's nothing in the world that could save you.
Okay, it's real.
That's so real.
Like, if you died, you messed up, basically.
Yeah, nothing in this world could actually save you if you die.
They have Hawkeye, so play position it.
They have Hawkeye.
i'm switching oh that's right position yourself guys right i have to position ourselves hawkeye's all about positioning so i can start like i can start hitting all right they're shooting my big wall they're shooting my big walls and he's shooting the big wall any heels i need to break this wall that's right i'm just trying not to i'm not trying to eat too much uh anti-heal anti-dog hawkeye it is blur fuck man we're fine we're fine get around He's boxed.
He's boxed.
Blur gets anti.
Oh, I'm dead.
That's fine.
Almost have coffee.
Next kill.
Nice kill.
Get down, they're already.
They're down.
They're healing.
They're back.
Take his wrist.
Oh, no.
You pushed that way too.
Do you know what I mean?
Hacking up.
Backing up?
It's the Hawkeye.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
That was me.
I didn't know what it was.
I shouldn't have pushed out.
Okay.
We might need a chillier, chillier, chillier, chillier.
No, we can't.
We can't.
Chillier, chillier.
You copy me and then...
Oh, we can't.
We should have ported of that, actually.
Can you touch?
Yep, yep, yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, You copy me copy me.
Oh It's unlucky.
It's fine.
Just fight this fight this copy the enemy damn baby can Do we TP oh no, it's fine.
I just die just die.
It's okay.
We can we still have we have Press G press G and return press G All right, I feel like I feel like the Emma is like not working.
I feel like you want to swap?
Yeah, I'm gonna go strange I'm gonna go strange.
Yeah, cuz I can't I mean, yeah, I mean Yes, Hawkeye.
Yeah, exactly.
I have ulti.
Doki, I'll wait for your ulti.
No, you copy, Yuzu copies me and then we all go in with that.
Okay, right now.
No, no, not yet.
Not yet.
Are you all here?
Yeah, do it now.
Yes, yes, yes.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay, I'm going.
Go, go, go.
Femi's alting.
Oh, my gosh.
She's already carrying me.
Luna, you can up.
Got it.
Oh, nice thing.
Luna, you can up.
Alt to save this fight.
They're down two.
Okay.
I'm coming back.
They're boxed in.
We can kill them.
We can kill them there.
All right.
I'm coming here.
I'm coming.
Go.
Go in.
Come back.
No, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
So if they punish all, we have to luna alt this, but we have to kite back in that luna alt.
Okay.
Because, okay, at first we kite back, but if he starts pushing us aggressively, the luna alts.
Yo, blurs up.
Blurs up.
Blurs pushed up.
Help up.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
They're gonna punch her all after this.
So we have to kite.
Get ready to kite.
Get ready to kite this.
Yeah, yeah, get out.
Get ready to kite.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, should I go fantastic and safe, to be honest?
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, I think we can hold it.
I think we can hold it more.
Actually?
Oh, it's fine.
I'm coming back.
Oh, no.
We die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point.
Die on point.
We have another fight here.
Just die on point.
I'll be able to get ulti really fast.
All right, okay.
Or do you want to keep on Ayrfus?
I think Iron Fist is.
Okay, okay, okay.
We can like shred tank and then we can just start.
He's just gonna be looking at us.
All right.
Start going up.
Don't get picked.
All right.
Gotta break it.
Whoever dies first has to play Strange.
I'm Strange right now.
You're a wall.
Go Hawkeye.
Hawkeye.
All right, I'm Altinas!
Oh my god, he's on me.
I got Walled off.
Oh no!
Okay, I'm switching Fantastic.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm gonna swap.
Do you think we need to get damage?
You got to back out of there.
You got to die or back out.
I don't know about damage.
Because they're able to tap us like a lot.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
I'm good.
I got out.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm like halfway to my alt again.
So I've never sent to my alt.
What the wrong?
Did they use Grudal yet?
Did they already use Grudal?
No, he did not.
Okay.
I'm going to keep being, I don't have cleanse for it yet.
He's usually getting cleansed.
I'm, we're fine.
I shielded him.
I walled him off.
All right.
My alt.
No more alt.
Yeah!
I got a literary.
I got.
I got Hawkeye.
We can keep pushing.
Keep pushing.
Alright, back up!
Back up!
I have ult soon as well.
We'll use his copy.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, use us.
We all, we engage first.
Okay.
Do you want me to hang around and like, try and get an ult off, on that?
Oh, the fucking wall came back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ready?
Go, go, copy, copy, copy.
Okay.
Nice.
Outside.
Flores right here.
Rocket.
Nice.
I got.
Hawkeye.
Keep going.
They're all dead.
They have no DPS.
Careful.
Get the rocket.
I died.
back up back up back up it's fine it's my fine i'm saving i'm saving uh i'm gonna save you i'm gonna save you back up back up back up i have all i have all i have i have i have to i have to save us all right they switched blur switched off of looking he's moving right now we have to when you die uh you say you have to swap off uh swap off loki because he's just gonna farm all to leave us i have all ready okay
I'm walling.
Nice.
It's fine.
I'm alting.
We're all in it.
Nice.
Two dead.
Groot, Groot, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
You want me out though?
I got scared.
My bad, bro.
It was you and him.
Stop bouncing on it, bro.
They're going to pour out.
Push, push, push.
They have one DPS now.
They only have two tanks.
I have ulti.
Copy me.
I'm running out.
Anyway, I put a wall in the alt.
Rocket, rocket.
I got rocket.
Rockets.
I'm on Yabbit.
I got, I'm on Yabbit.
Then he's alting.
She's one.
Got him!
Use everything!
This is last fight!
Only- only- Nice!
Nice!
Okay,
good swaps, good swaps.
Nice swaps, good, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I go Iron Fist this one because we're pushing?
I think- Try Iron Fist and if it doesn't work, we do fantastic.
Okay.
I'll try Emma first and then I can go back to- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't have- Oh, we can go back.
Petty on attack here.
Whoa, wait.
Coachman said he can be in VC with us.
He was told that he can be in VC with us to coach us.
Nice.
Wait.
What?
Whoa.
Hop in.
Apparently the production team said they want him to join us.
Hold up.
Coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach.
Okay, he's in trim right now, but...
Coach, coach!
Is he gonna come later?
Yeah, he's gonna come later.
He said he's the cat right now.
Okay, okay.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Alright.
I'm getting hard focused by their DP.
They're literally, like, trying to kill...
Trying to kill me first.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah, they were... I saw...
Both of them were trying solo at me.
Oh.
Let's go.
That sticker is so cute.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, ow.
That's so sad, man.
We did not look.
It's so sad.
You have Spider-Man?
It's fine.
I...
That Wolverine's fine.
Wolverine.
I got you guys.
Bastard blur!
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him!
He got away, he dashed.
Are you running?
Do we pop this passive?
Yeah, I don't know actually.
I didn't see it.
It did pop.
Oh, he got my ass!
Oh, he took you to the...
I am going...
Mr. Fantastic.
I don't know.
You're blacked off, you're blacked off.
He's fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I guess I'll do it.
I'll do it.
soon it's just the pennies disgusting conversation combination are we able to like somehow go grew instead of i'm going back i'm going back i'm going back all right the wolf is gonna like target me it's fine it's fine help me help me help me thank you passive passive we pop passive we pop passive i'm starting i have all here i have all here we're gonna breast this okay get the big wall break his big wall all right ready go go go go
I got this, I got this, I got this, I got this, nice, nice, nice.
Push up, push up, push up.
Alt and five.
Get that rocket, get the rocket out if you can.
I'm going over to rocket out.
He's trying to ult me, or yeah, he got me.
We have all of you guys defensive?
That's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They canceled my...
Wait, they used my...
I just died, just died.
They used a brutal ult.
They wasted it.
Yeah, yeah, just die here.
Just die here.
Okay, okay, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Just die.
Why are they taking forever?
Okay.
Why did they take it forever to kill me?
Yeah, I know.
This is the slowest planned death ever.
I wasn't even Wolverine's initial target.
You were a coincidental.
Also, like, does anyone know I played Moon Knight?
Does anyone know I played Moon Knight?
No.
I do.
Okay.
Talk to Moon Knight?
Oh, okay.
Let's switch to the triple teams.
Triple teams.
Yeah, our tank.
Well, I got all first.
I got all first.
Okay.
We got it.
Here I got you.
I'm out.
All right.
About the ult.
Here you go.
I have.
I have you ult.
I'm ulting.
I got pinny.
Oh, yeah.
That's fine.
He's three.
Three?
Okay.
Flare.
Stop it.
Okay.
He caught out.
That's good.
I got pinny.
Use it.
Hey, okay, nice, nice, nice toy.
They're boxing in.
Oh, my God.
Anti.
And I'm gonna use this after.
Wait, no way, snowball, no way else.
No way else, we win this.
Okay, I'm gonna ult here.
If I can?
Oh no, oh my.
He threw us into the mines.
He threw us in the mines, yeah...
I have ulti.
We can save it.
Okay, um, heavenly.
Swapped and Moonlight right now.
Go ahead.
I swapped.
Yeah, yeah.
Swapped and we're gonna use mine and we engage here.
We can go in with it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll be able to kill them.
Are you ready?
Yep.
Three, two, one, go.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
All right, I'm going to breaking it.
I'm going for it.
Over in behind again.
He got me.
Did you get anyone?
I got out.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Reloading.
I saw the penny.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Penny, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
They're real, they're rising.
I'm on group, I'm on focus, focus group, group one, group one, group one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wolverine, Wolverine, Wolverine.
I got rocket, I got rocket, I got rocket, Wolverine, Wolverine.
Focus, Wolverine.
Portally, portally, portally.
Strange, focus on strange, just strange.
Hold on, I'm pushing both healers right here.
Nice, nice, nice.
One healer dead.
I'm blocking, I'm blocking, I'm body blocking.
They're good.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ruby's out of position over here.
They're running, okay, they're, if they stay on Penny, stay on Moon Knight.
They're still on Penny, so we win this.
You need me to switch still, or I feel like I'm kidnapping.
Yeah, you're good, good, good.
Just kidnap the Grood non-stop.
That's all you have to do.
Yeah, yeah.
And we just turn on him.
Should I be pushing the...
You're not grabbing me that easy, big dog.
That's fine, that's fine.
One person push card, and then the rest just push up a bit.
I almost have coffee.
Where I see you in there, dog.
The moment we use coffee instantly.
The moment we get it.
We alting, just to push them back.
That's nice to push up.
Back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, save our save them, save them, can.
I go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, nice, nice.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
I'm alting, I'm alting, I'm alting.
After this, I can all I need help here.
I need help here.
Oh, take it.
Keep engaging!
We got a Goswari!
Good, good, nice, nice, good.
Luverine dead, Wolfwing, nice, nice.
I'm looking support.
Go too.
Guppy's by herself.
Ichi, close, close, close, close.
We're behind, close, close.
Keep pushing.
Three on cards.
Push up, block it.
Back up!
Moon Knight.
Swap off Moon Knight.
You're on Storm.
We don't need Moon Knight.
We need Headscan.
Oh, wait.
Actually, yeah, we need Headscan for this.
Come on.
This guy wants a...
This Groot wants an alt so bad.
He's so in my face.
The Wolverine has alt.
So, just make sure you don't get close to the Wolverine.
That's all you have to do.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see the We need to get blur the fuck off he's one.
I almost have both of you.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, that's bad.
I didn't get a heal that fuck.
We can get Groot.
Nice.
Keep up.
Give him.
I've got you.
Got you.
We're even.
We're even, push up a little bit.
We have storm bolting.
Do we have a support?
No, it's going to get damage by it.
There was nothing we could do there.
No, we're still fine.
We're only down one.
We're still fine.
Fight this.
Focus on...
I'm dead.
I have ulti though.
Could we pair Gambit ulti?
I'm dead.
I have my ult.
Back up.
John, Jeff Nato.
Let's pair ultis.
Should I go strange instead?
Yeah, go strange.
Go strange here.
Yeah, yeah.
We have we have thrills.
Yeah, copy me here.
And then we use Hawkeye.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
I'm shooting the...
I'm going for the ultimate.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
I'm shooting, I'm shooting still?
Okay, he's dead, but he's dead, but he's dead.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Push up, push up, push up!
Don't let them free my beacon!
I got her, I got her, I got her, I got her!
Get the rocket, get the rocket!
Hey, hey, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump!
Somebody stay on it!
Don't worry, I got it.
I want it.
It's fighting time!
I'm all here, I'm all here.
Ready?
Okay, get it!
Oh, she got off it?
It's fine!
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
Let's go!
Oh, I can't have the penny over the point.
Yes!
Okay.
Holy shit.
It's...
Okay, Balila.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Funny letter number.
I was losing my mind.
Those swaps are good.
Good call on all the swaps, yeah.
That was some good ass swaps.
Oh my god.
Jeez, guys.
We're in the finals automatically.
Yes!
the finals even we lose the next one doesn't matter we're in the finals oh my goodness jesus i feel like i feel like we're doing our team is doing a really good job of supporting yeah yeah and letting him like just run around yeah see see we have more comps
The Wolverine one wasn't even planned.
We can just pull that one out of our ass.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, let me ask.
Oh, he was like, oh, Gomez was like, oh, I heard on IML stream I could join in, but I'm not sure anymore.
All right.
But GG's guys, I'm proud of all of you.
I am so proud.
That was some good call-out.
I'm so thankful that Heavenly is, like, so flexible into...
Yeah.
I can play anything, except for Gambit, apparently.
No, he has two pages of instructions.
No, I don't blame you.
I...
But, oh my God, Yuzu, though.
My God, look at your stats, Yuzu.
That's our under-ranker here.
Thank you.
oh my god user was insane I feel bad yeah I saw you MVP like the whole game yeah you just got one more kill more than here and then stole it from here that's fucked up that's not nice that's fucked up yeah it's fucked up so who wait who plays that
we go against Amaz yeah we go right next right away okay yeah yeah
uh was i was i not supposed to leave oh yeah oh oh can you invite me back oh okay yeah yeah oh never mind never mind it was a jk gomas can't join in okay that's fine okay that's good yeah oh wait we'll win it we'll win in his honor it's okay yeah yeah we'll win in his honor i think it's a break time right got you well break time okay i'm gonna pee i also have to pee all right for the last game to the last game yeah it's like no pressure we're in the finals automatically we can we don't have to we it would be cool to win but you know no pressure we should yeah yeah try your best yeah try our best yeah just don't know pressure i'll be right back okay key break
oh what that means i'm happy my team to pass for free real well to know when to swap to yeah
I'm just happy Everyone did their part Yeah Because like they knew what to do to swap as well Because I don't know I don't have like all the knowledge of counter swapping Because I didn't play this season As much Well I mean I did guys I didn't want to show it But because Wait I don't want to No actually I can't show it because I don't want jinx us I don't want it You know what it's I don't care For a second I don't care
I played rank for two days And then I like Okay wait In 5.2 hours
So But it's like But it's I mostly played Gambit though It was mostly Gambit too
yeah it is really I was very fortunate that Gambit is very strong for a second I don't care I'm just I'm I was really nervous I honestly was incredibly nervous like my manager was like was like are you sure you want to do this I can't believe man oh my god i can't believe i'm so happy i my goal is like i hope we win a game but look at us we won two games we have i know we won two games guys i'm proud of all of us we're doing so good oh my god i mean we're fighting are we fighting doobie's team again or wait no no shoto's team has to fight doobie's team right after our game so our first and second is determined by whether or not Trudeau's team beats Doobie's team.
Okay, okay.
So, we're not, we're not the next up then.
No, we are.
We are.
Oh, oh.
Apparently, are we?
I thought we are, right?
You are?
I would think that they are because we're in the lead.
Then they're next.
So, whoever wins the next game is our finals.
Oh, man.
So we already went up against everyone then, right?
No, we have Amalee's team after.
Oh, Amalee's team is next.
We are up next, yeah.
They just haven't given...
They're just on a break right now.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Oh, I'm so nervous.
I'm not...
I'm okay now, because I know we're in the finals, and for a second is fun with me.
Hello.
Never settled, Doki.
Never.
Aim for the stars.
I know.
We got it.
We can win.
We can do it.
We have the skill.
Aim for the stars.
Oh my gosh.
Bro, I'm getting one guy.
My chat doesn't even know who's next.
Like, they're like, no, it's not.
No, it guys.
It's Shona versus Scooby next.
Because the graphics are wrong, I think.
I'm looking at match order.
Like, if you go back in the VOD, you can see it.
um so i don't i think it's so it was dubie versus joki next is dubie versus shoto and then next after that is us versus ama if we're this looks this looks right yeah because it's whatever's on top goes first and then whatever's on bottom goes second yeah okay it's not wrong i just can't okay we got a nice break again dubie versus shoto next oh okay so we get to watch if you i can't read i've illustrated that so many times today we were we were playing a scream earlier and there's a button when you pause it says continue and then continue and i i think wait no one says confirm and one says continue and i just hit continue because continue and confirm look like the same word and i started the game for everyone and and heavenly was eating
yeah oh yeah
I'm sorry we can just relax now we can relax relaxing it's hard it's too hard I'm too scared it's okay it's okay whatever happens we get at least 2.5k right right that's first place right I don't remember I don't remember at what the price I don't remember um all right rule set i don't remember i remember it was like oh we get 3.3 k whatever happens in the end oh divided by six my monitors just died oh my my my rivals just crashed oh oh no oh my god
okay uh send and close give me back my game
hey i'm back Hey, had a little TikTok break.
Did that happen?
Nice.
My driver is exploded.
They're coming back.
My driver's exploded.
Oh, no.
That's okay.
We can ask them to pause the game for like 30, do a 30 minute break and can drive the best by it.
Yeah, no, no, it's okay.
I've been having like random driver crashes.
Like I've updated to the newest ones and it just has issues.
I don't know why.
Oh, yeah.
That's why you never update newest drivers.
oh yeah if i don't update newest drivers it happens more i've been on the same nvidia driver since i plugged this graphics card in my computer because when i updated it once everything fell apart so i was like yep go back no it's actually a windows 11 issue because it's only started happening after i after i had to swap because windows 11 sucks ass it does suck wait none of y'all have like a microsoft sponsorship right well not anymore i'm getting nice going guys what if what if we and we give we give sk siloed for her last game no no thank you if you if you if you squash a first time player then i don't believe in this but don't you guys come on we can give her give her a chance to finally how about we be nice and ban it yeah you don't want me to target ben
the thing is guys saying is yeah that's self-love you know what all right try and out ban me it's a rank ban i i like my odds and gotcha okay but this is our first ban and then we gotcha who who wins the second ban
that's awesome i'm so down
No, I should have terrible gotcha life, but...
Gacha.
Gacha,
gacha, gacha, gacha.
I'm just figuring it out.
I think it'd be fun, you know?
What if, like, to see who wins the band?
Yeah.
So...
we've been against both of those teams already right yeah yeah so yeah oh are they playing a game right yeah so they're playing they're starting now so the thing is whoever wins this game we're going to be playing the next and it'll be best of three oh so amily is like out yes okay once you're o and two you're you're fully out there's no coming yeah okay okay what's your pickums for this one which team do you think is coming out on top honestly it's showedo's team pulled the heck through that was crazy i i i put money on doobie's team blur is just so nasty i'm kind of scared of him yeah blur is like more versatile in what he can play we said sk was nasty too but yeah okay maybe maybe he's nasty i think it's because like sk has been doing like flashy plays like more so like i have to kill people like so she's like flanking a lot but flanking is farming clips like but flanking we're going on a tick tock but the thing is flanking is like you know high reward uh high risk so like
everyone's been turning around on her and the moment she dies like the whole the front line like the whole front line collapses oh i see
storm ban interesting i
love not banning their bucky is so interesting confident going through i mean they're running hella namor oh whoops i forgot to open mouse the stream i was fucking chats were just looking at me is it gonna be like a bucky div i can't they're staring at you the bucky oh they're going to run bucky versus bucky oh wait storm that's interesting that's crazy they didn't run oh i guess they did because they were scared of lur's storm yeah yeah gambit back
uh that doobie the the skin that doobie is wearing that cloak and dagger skin it reminds me of like a sprite can sprite sponsor all right we
get to see his bucky guys whoa okay yeah well blur is not playing bucky where's my bucky 1v1 what the fuck oh my god he gets to finally play The thing is, the reason why I also banned his Bucky too is because I saw his, I saw all his, all he's been practicing was Bucky the last two days.
Can he aim good?
That's what he, that's what Connor said.
I didn't say he said it.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh my God.
Yeah, plant the seed, plant the wall.
Uh-huh.
Punch.
Squid.
Oh.
squid pov nice marvel rivals that's unfortunately that they got domination as their map too domination is such a hard like it's it's a very refreshing game mode in the tournament yeah because you gotta adjust so fast yeah how fast the games are looks like dubious team is winning
i like that i've never seen this no more skin what is this that's the Dave the dead.
Oh, Dave the dead.
Oh, okay.
What the hell are you eating?
He's so blue.
Lazy's head.
It's so blue.
He's a smurf.
The front is cool, though.
I really like the front too.
I don't doubt it.
I'm just saying he's blue as hell.
That's true.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
I'll take it back.
Blur my bad.
See?
smurfing he got him guys oh my god oh no yeah that is so insane maybe he is nasty dude what did i say
i mean we did ben we did the hell of ben right on on this team see that's why we got yeah that's why we got rid of the team up for them so they can't yeah that's why that's why we did that so they won't have the Oh, oh, oh, oh, he's oh, no, he ran her over.
Oh, do they have a support of?
They did.
I'll be right back.
I got to use the bathroom.
They have a rocket right after.
Enjoy the amplifier.
Oh, oh my God.
Oh, my God.
This is nasty.
Oh, okay, God.
There we go.
I was going to say it.
Oh, my God.
oh my god
that's so crazy that was good that was good alt management on her team
um running out of water uh get water go get some more soon you got 40 seconds soon oh shit you're right there's matches yeah go now go now go now you're back hey he's dancing he's dancing hey he's dancing hey hey hey Hey, hey, hey!
Is this allowed?
Um...
What do you mean?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Did you hear that?
Wait, what did he say?
He kind of goes, I think Blur is just such an annoying person on Team Doobie.
Yeah.
more hella combo like the team up is so strong
that's crazy
oh oh oh oh he's going band for band up there damn oh oh oh oh wow oh oh they got him that was insane oh my all right he's he's been playing in their faces a little bit it too much she got his ass it's the cockiness i
really don't like this map is really hard for me i don't like this set of maps i feel like i lose a lot i mean at least it's played so i don't think there's like a good chance of it being played against i i think it's just random maps each time so i don't think it has any bearing yeah oh oh i'm like paranoid my stuff is gonna turn off because stuff turned I'm sorry no no I that's like a chronic problem that I've been having it's just me and it's just once and then it stops it's I don't know what's wrong it might be my GPU but I just got a new one so it should be okay oh you've planted the seeds of doubt okay sorry my back I'm back welcome back you know it'd be hella evil as if my power went out it's gone out four times in the past two weeks oh don't say that don't say that i feel like you get a pause for that right yeah my power grid explodes you get a pause we yeah maybe we can grab an emergency sub i'll go to my friend's house and use her yeah move i gotta use your stuff oh jesus
oh that's crazy i can't believe he lives
well they got it we're about to go to our next match.
We're going against SK?
It's all these.
Okay.
Yeah.
They're going to win.
I mean, yeah, they're going to win this.
We're up against Duby after.
Yeah, right up against Amas.
No, no, after.
I thought Amalie was out.
No, but we still, we had to play everyone.
We had to play everyone once.
We still play Maddie against them.
I see.
Yeah.
Okay.
But like in the finals, we play against Duby's team if they win this.
Hmm.
I like how excited Connor is.
It's really fun.
He's a very competitive person, isn't he?
I know he used to play Apex, too, a lot.
Oh, yeah, I forgot about that.
He had, like, an Apex arc, a League arc.
Yeah.
He's just a very competitive person, too.
Mm-hmm.
Earlier, he was like, I'm really glad we're doing competitive games.
Yeah, they got the Emma Alt in time.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm surprised he didn't portal.
The Emma Alt of Doom and Despair.
Yeah.
I'm surprised they didn't they didn't portal it
that was a good game that was hard yeah
god dang all right we just gotta wait for our lobby okay excited losing the stream getting ready cracking knuckles opening my game hoping it doesn't crack again locking in oh all right someone invite me
i think i have too many things open okay close that close that oh
okay yeah okay oh is it time how do i Yeah.
Uh, the button near the word team.
See, uh, join in the top or top right.
Can I get an invite, please?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Yay.
We're on the wrong side, guys.
It's the right side.
Oh.
I like how y'all, y'all followed me.
Not me though.
I thought for myself.
Yes.
They were like, yeah, we should be joking on the left side.
I didn't know there were actual names like written on the team.
I thought it was just team one.
I also didn't know.
So are we going back to back after this?
Oh, no, we...
I think we'll get a short break.
Okay, okay, okay.
We have to...
There's a bat.
We have to do the bat I'm going to be doing because look at the map.
Okay, got it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
back to random okay wouldn't be funny if it goes back they ceded it so that's the map
all right here we go y'all there we go
oh oh yeah i forgot to say i is our stand for ready yeah oh they're in restroom i'm r though i didn't ask you guys if you're ready but i know i'm ready you're ready we're ready yes captain yes glory to the donkey empire man shiny let's go choo choo choo
What do we get if we win?
Money.
Oh, shit.
Did you not know?
Did you not look?
Did not know we get money?
Since he didn't know, I'll take his money.
Yeah, me too.
Good choice.
Yeah, let's all split Heavenly's money.
Yeah, yeah, he's just playing a pit.
Yeah, he's playing for fun.
Let's split his pool.
Yeah, yeah.
We're not.
We're here for the money, right, guy?
What's fun?
I don't know what that means.
yeah getting money is fun
marbel rye bells
you're so tired of this stupid ai baby what what uh hold on what the are you talking talking about oh match is starting never mind okay you're safe this time buddy map we're getting again domination okay it's domination okay all right then not all right no I know what to man we're not gotching this is the map that they played earlier no this domination is different oh
my favorite I'm swimming I'm under the water Yeah we banish I love
Alright No more gotcha time Cause this map is strong We're against I wonder who they're gonna target Man Me too You think they're gonna leave a gambit I don't Have we seen We played a gambit game We played one gambit one without Yeah Oh Mr. Fantastic That's for you.
You gotta bear a sidelog now.
Take the funnel away.
That's my main.
Don't say that.
What the fuck?
I'm sorry.
That's not my main.
That's not his main, guys.
He's lying.
That's actually not his main.
For those who are wondering, we're not actually lying.
My main is, Jeff.
That's right.
you really man pick your hero or villain i'm not judging all right okay here we go i'll show uh what do we do here it's the same it's just it's the same
my group wasn't even doing nothing no you had crazy ults though bro yeah you also were crazy yeah and i like uh anti did so there was so much damage yeah each and every time is so good i have to get a little strange on them oh it's this one yeah i'm not playing penny on this fuck that oh yeah be careful of that you know how to deal with hella right hella on this map i don't no no for our iron fist i'm you know how to deal with hella right uh as long as you don't get stunned you should be fine
See there.
Oh, they're not coming out.
Oh, they're a trap.
They don't want to show their cop.
They don't...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, guys, seven, seven seconds, seven seconds!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Three, two, one!
All you need to do is capture the missionary.
Got it.
Oh, the running button.
Are we gonna keep going left?
Oh, right.
Oh, they're... Yeah, they're...
right right or straight on we gotta have to swap off lucky here again yeah yeah i got the buck wall i'm going right slowly you guys can go for me tanks can come through from yeah we're going back we're going man we're going yeah don't worry we can help you here don't worry your friend
yeah Yeah, there's so much focus on that.
Eskate!
Ah!
Oh no, it's fine.
It's okay.
We might have to give.
We're down too.
Yeah, it's fine, but we can get- we can just stay here for as long as we can.
We're getting- we're getting- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're getting Poe in charge.
No, yeah, it's fine.
We're just getting all charged.
Yeah, see what they wasted that to get that point.
Just don't use anything.
We don't have anything.
Oh!
Okay.
Just back out.
I heard the A word.
It's time to go.
It's fine.
Loki here?
Swap off?
Oh, wait, never mind.
It's fine.
You're fine for now.
We might...
We might have to swap off Iron Fist because...
No worries.
Do you want to go tank?
I'll go DPS.
Yep.
Yeah, okay.
Just back up, back up, back up.
Heavenly back up, back up, back up.
Okay!
What do we want for DPS?
Um... In the more?
In the more is fine.
Okay.
What's the word?
Alright, here you go.
go up i will here you guys ready we're going to engage with that yeah three two one go
anti they use double support out they double support all this go for a cloak look for a cloak oh they broke it
do you copy me copy me copy me copy me okay when you will see it okay i will think Oh damn.
Ohhh.
I don't have cleanse.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky.
I got him.
Nice.
Oh, I gave her a mean right click.
Oh my god.
Master in her face.
We're gonna check.
Yeah, that was good.
It's moon night time.
You definitely got to go.
You gotta get on Loki now.
They got the moon night.
Yeah, they want you.
Yeah yeah yeah You guys Okay We'll use invisible here So we can get that swap in Okay Well you try and Okay Use it defensively still We'll still use it defensively But use it like In a way where It's gonna be your judgment
We get strange We get strange Yeah he's out of position Nice Nice nice Nice Strange change change change change change okay i'm gonna ult them i can alt them yeah yeah yeah when they portal yeah and i'll i'll first and then you they're here but they're not oh they didn't decide portal I guess they're gonna use it for last play I'm ulting this ready
don't I won't fight that nice nice nice better get in the invisible yeah yeah got them nice nice I'm stuck I'm stunned I got you I got you
hi armor care back line care back line care back line it's fine oh it's not fine it's not It's fine for me.
It's fine.
No, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
We still have a fight.
Okay.
These LTs.
Do you want our portal?
We can portal.
No, no.
Don't portal.
We're gonna portal last fight.
We still can't have a copy, too.
All right.
Come here.
Come with me.
We wait.
It's fine.
All right, we gotta go.
We go.
Go up, go up, go up.
Go up here.
We take his high ground.
We take his high ground away.
Here.
I'm dropping.
SK's out of the fight right now.
Nice.
I got him.
SK altered herself?
Got it.
Got her, guys.
Nice.
The whale.
I have copy.
Get the cloak.
Nice.
They have to pour it.
They have.
I'm gonna go up.
the camp portal nice nice oh my god so why does she alt herself she was alting all three supports all of us were up there oh and then i in bone for that yeah i anti-hide her in time they they're playing uh penny now they're playing penny i don't know if that was like an excessive no more but it was really funny um do you want me to play wolf or i can go strange as well i think i think it's fine fine for now i can i can go tank you want to go back to dps uh are they still on bucky or no but uh if they're not bucky you can see pretty well to be honest i don't know if we need to okay sorry let's just play if you keep for now and then if it doesn't work we swap back to our original comp okay can do okay if your discord crashes tell us in in game chat so we can pause for you yeah i didn't say we see but i don't know if you heard me no no oh now i can hear you oh now i can hear Okay.
Now we can hear you.
Yes.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna play strange here.
Okay.
I'm totally fine with that.
I thought we were on the right side.
I went to the right entrance instead.
I was like, we're right.
Where's the door?
Where is everyone?
No, I was like, where's my door?
I'm like, where's my door?
What?
They're putting Ska on tank now.
I missed my anti.
Oh, let him know.
I have ulti.
I have ulti so stabilize we can.
Don't get picked here.
Free?
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, actually.
Three, two, one.
They're down.
Let's keep going.
Let's keep it.
Get me, get me, get me, get me.
Got him, nice, nice, nice.
Mag is alone.
Mega's alone on the left.
Stagger him, kill him.
Yeah, max can do a lot of damage.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You never stagger that.
Good job, good job, good job.
You just stagger swishies.
Get back here!
Yes!
This team is just so fucking free!
I'm playing the game with both of my feet!
Oh, I've never heard that remix before.
That's new to me.
I have ulti.
That's good.
Okay, uh, try and like hide for it.
Hide for it.
And then fly up and I'll...
I'm going, I'm going above.
I'm going...
Actually, no.
I can play aggro.
Okay.
Oh oh oh oh Punisher on the side Okay, I got you I got you I got you If you can't look for a stranger Portal bro Oh no We're down one we're down one They ulted, they ulted, Gambit ulted Punisher ulted Punisher ulted Back up Oh wait, is a server?
Oh, they're flagged right now Yeah, they're slag I'm now
We're down to healer, we're down to healer It's fine, fight Die on point, die on point down point okay okay die just down point just down point oh that server lag was bullshit hey 60 61 i got that server lag too yeah i i had a little bit of i still have ulti i was saving i couldn't i couldn't do anything uh copy me and then yeah and then we go with the stranger wait for me wait for me yeah back back wait wait don't don't push up why does it feel right let's go
I'm gonna let you heal more.
I'm gonna let you hear.
Okay.
We're ready?
You can copy me?
My fucking mind.
Etsy?
Etsy too?
Look for the...
Wait, just wait for that.
Wait for that.
Wait for that to get out.
And then ult.
Okay, look for the ult.
Look for the ult.
Yo, multiple ult.
I got shielded.
It got shielded.
It's fine.
Alting this.
Go, go, go.
Oh, okay.
They all did.
Cook here, cook here, cook here, cook here.
Ah.
It's fine, it's fine.
Punisher ate it.
He broke it.
Yeah, you have to do it fast.
You have to do it fast.
Yeah, I tried to, I was in a bad spot.
Nice block, nice block.
All right, I'm stepping on point.
Invis, Invis, one, Invis, one, Invis, one.
Invis, they're down to healer.
Down to healer, down to healer.
Down to healer.
They're on the left.
I got him.
I'm going to go for help.
Cat point.
He's alone.
Got her.
You have a killer right now.
Nice kill.
We don't have any...
We got...
Okay, don't heal.
Don't heal.
Don't let our heal too much.
Let our sue heal.
Come back.
We can heal the mag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need to build this up.
So let the sue heal.
They're just walking up.
I'm going to use the portal as the last fight.
Come on to my...
I'm going to look to our left.
There are left.
on left too careful there's two on left oh it's going hard left they're really deep in their left it's fine okay one healer is dead left uh uh what's his name he's through it he's down it's fine
get off of my supports I got a I got a I got a I got fun car into yeah i saw that that was insane sk more like bb what did you talk about oh my god oh i don't care i love it i love it yeah dude three-time mvp crazy yeah look at that oh
let's go do we go straight to the finals like we played i feel like they give us a break or something yeah i want a little break here just a tiny little break as a treat yeah please please break break please
uh like maybe like a dinner break guys we're 300 guys a dinner break yeah that's yeah that's how yeah yeah can we come back in 30 minutes like i'm gonna order food let's make this a two-day venture can you come back another day man i'm tired yeah yeah day two day two oh my god day two yeah yeah for sure day two i don't think i'm gonna be cracked out like this tomorrow i think this is i have to play our
i got our creators tomorrow they nerf the venator i don't know what any of that means i haven't played it yet oh i'm like what do you mean that's okay is our creators worth getting into i keep hearing i mean right now yes yeah it's fun yeah it's just a fun time i didn't have too much uh interest when i tried it out it was okay i really like the finals which was the game that the same team made oh the finals made that yeah i didn't know that yeah i love the finals if you so the way that uh arc raiders goes is that solos and duos people are like pretty chill once you enter trios it's like a blood bath it's just apex people want to kill you and rip your head off so they don't want to don't shoot there's no don't shoot sometimes but it's the most don't shoot people are like solos uh and then duo sometimes oh wait
i'm just we made it to the finals i'm proud of y'all i'm whatever happens we did it we got in the finals i'm such a genius so my ads are running but that doesn't mean people have to watch go to the other channel right now oh my god i'm just glad that we made it did they say we has a break or what i think it's just like five like it was like a five minutes or something I feel good.
I'm okay.
I'm shaking.
I'm so scared.
Can I have a, can I get my water then?
Yeah, I think so.
They're still interviewing.
They're interviewing right now.
Go get your water.
Oh, okay.
I'm going to disassociate for a bit, too.
I'm being disassociated.
Guys, I'm going to.
I'm looking at DoorDash.
I'm going to disassociate for a bit.
I need to calm down.
Yo, what do I get for dinner?
Thoughts?
I'm getting fun.
Pizza.
Get pizza.
oh pizza yeah yeah pizza really good oh my god um i'm really proud of my team we didn't practice we strategized a lot i i used my time because like all of our schedules put mine up um heaven we're just gonna keep we're gonna keep doing our best and and working together and and swapping when when it used to and it'll be okay like heavenly only played with us for two hours for today like yesterday he couldn't like that was the first time we were able to play together as a team like two hours before the stream uh before the tournament because like uh because he couldn't make it to yesterday's scrim so so i'm really proud of us we're able to like do that this well we're not having that much practice together as a team yeah i'm so happy tomorrow you'll be i was so stressed out yeah i fucking wish really stressed out
I thought I muted the soundboard how is it still coming through that's insane is it like did you just do it on a go XLR uh it's a yeah it's like it's a ported through one yeah I was like I fucking muted all your soundboards on this screen I was not having it I was not having the soundboard shit that is so funny oh my god yeah um but oh my gosh i'm just at a really chinese point in our life um oh she don't want to talk to us no more oh sorry i was just associating us you're good you're good you're good i'm so i'm just you whatever happens that we made it to the they said we're getting it they said we're getting a quick break thank oh oh how quick is that okay i would say the bathroom order food yeah it's a five it is five okay okay yeah i know that my teammates need to be on my screen to get i know that um the thing is like my supports aren't even going to go straight in anyway the reason why i don't do that for my supports is that like i i'm more i'm trying to make sure because i have
to make the reaction quick so like i can't just like run back and then all i'm i'm focusing on the fact that my dps and tanks are in front of me and they are the most important people to get the ult so like if I have to make a snap decision I'm not gonna have to I'm not gonna look back and then make sure everyone's in my view and then I'll I have to make a snap decision in my ult and be like these are the people that I need to do damage that can do damage yeah who are we going up against Duby yeah our next match is with yeah yeah okay best of three best of three technically we never went to losers so i don't think there's losers in this one no there's no i wanted my extra free one point so it's best two out of our best so we have to play two times instead of three times or one time
each match they ban they do bands again it's the rank bands it's the same i think they might just do that i do the same bands or they target new bands to make it work Okay.
So, the thing is, we have to win two games, basically, instead of one.
Oh, wait, what the...
Okay.
I'm trying to remember what were the bans that we did.
I mean, Dubey's team is very strong.
Like, it's just...
Blur is just a very strong player.
I forget.
Yeah, Blur is really strong.
You know what they...
Do you know what they banned out?
Oh yeah, I'm going to look at my history and see what they banned out.
Blah.
Notice this.
They banned out Mag and Invis.
I think they did the Invis just so they can run Wolf.
No.
my friend once was like can i watch the replay of your game against bro i don't know i'll give you my replay did it copy did i do it i think you can oh is it that oh it is okay i got the replay code yeah my family's like guys oh just watching the countdown slowly yeah i'm gonna restart my game real quick all right okay okay just because i've been lagging oh no that's not good
i gotta play gambit let's go
yeah this is the games have all been very fun yeah well it's because well to be fair it's we're winning so yeah we got to give context as to why we're having fun we had close games though you know yeah there are some very tight games i mean doobie's team is very strong so the games have been very very tight you know that was that was fun that was fun all right to my sound guy the people that you told me to bring up in this grade oh
okay 30 30 seconds 30 seconds no 30 seconds no give us five more minutes five more minutes please please
um I like how I looked at my I looked at what we banned and I already forgot He's back Why did I ban?
I banned Okay, Bucky, hello Okay Hmm
Cammin May I get an invite?
Yeah, I'm going, I'm joining the thing right now Oh wait It's a new one?
They started a new lobby.
Nice.
I'm waiting for my invite.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Yay.
Tank.
We're in the, we're in the, don't worry guys.
We're on the right side this time.
You mean the left side?
Yeah, the left side.
All right.
There we go.
Before y'all jump my ass.
No, I saw that.
First round map.
Oh, random domination map and then lose...
Wait, are we doing this?
I don't know if they're actually doing this type...
Loser picks.
Oh, loser picks?
No, no, random domination map.
Then second map, the loser picks.
Wow.
Never done that before.
That's just like...
Like actually competitive is like that.
Oh, that's car.
Okay, the pizza places near me were closed.
I got Thai food.
Oh, no.
Pizza being closed, usually pizza is like the one that's 24-7.
No, there's one place near me that does it so good and they close it.
So my chat's like, do I keep rolling and platinum silver?
The ranks just reset, guys.
Everyone's ranks just reset.
They're not actually platinum silver.
this is so good this is the only time where I tried ranked and I won all 10 placements good for you my placements were ass same it was like 50-50 apparently everyone starts at bronze 3 so I just ended I started bronze 3 and then I ended in gold 2 oh yeah perfect That's a crazy good clan.
I had Elo Terrorizers in my games.
Like they were like not real.
I don't even know what was going on there.
The guy with the 600 damage and the one kill, that was in one of my placements.
And he was screaming at me!
I didn't heal him enough.
My bad.
Elo Terrorists are out there everywhere.
I simply told myself I will only open voice comms when I get to higher Elo.
it's they're low-key sometimes people are just as mean like yeah yeah I think Rivals has is like almost as toxic as Valorant now oh yeah the amount of times where it's like you open calm and you just like give a give like a call out and then they just like they're like oh woman I don't talk gonna lose I don't I'm not gonna talk to you anymore yeah so I never use voice comes all I do is
Oh, they're doing an interview right now with Doobie's team, so we're just waiting.
Are they going to interview you next?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
We'll see.
Hey, Doki.
Hello.
Would you like to come up and do one more interview?
Oh, yeah, sure.
Okay, I guess I am doing an interview.
It's also Monkey Channel 2.
Oh, which channel am the predictor?
Which one?
Do I just go to the main channel?
uh mouse and monkey okay so i can just go right now yeah okay cool oh gotta pull up this all right see you guys there hello hey guys undefeated so far don't don't don't don't jinx this man don't
i will counteract it you're gonna do great I'm proud of you.
You're amazing and you're a great gambit player.
Oh, thank you And then you're gonna ban my gambit now like No, oh no I hope they don't ban your gambit.
I've been loving that Jeff strat you guys have been doing.
Oh, wait the Jeff strat?
Oh, then we're all yeah.
Yeah.
They don't know what we're doing.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we're preventing the stream snipers Oh So you guys had that game against to be it was very close was yeah did you expect it to be that close were you i did because um i know that some of the players on dubious teams and like what they play i know like ugla is one them i know blur is a very very good fps player because he is apex predator um for many seasons so like i know he's a very he basically his fps skills can transfer to any game so okay um so like i knew his dps was really strong um and they're very coordinated too and he's very flexible so like he could play a lot of characters so like a lot of things yeah so like we can't really target ban him so um at best like we try our best to like strategically what can we survive like the most makes sense and you know there's some ults that we can't survive so we have to ban that true is there any strategy change you're gonna do going into this or you just play on the same game and how can it take you to the victory we'll
see we'll see how it goes like it really depends on what they're trying to ban because we know our band line um and so it's like what if obviously they want to try and ban something else on us because their first band line didn't work out i mean it did but like in a way where they want to win the next game so obviously they'll try to do a different ban to see which will actually have help them win the game so our strategy just depends on what their band line is because that's how our comps change instantly.
Yeah, I've seen your text channel.
You guys have got like the Bible of strategies to look at.
The little notepad that I used, right?
There's so many notepads of like, if this happens, it's like a flowchart extravaganza.
Yeah, like a little flowchart.
If they ban this, we go to this.
If they ban that, we go to this.
But my team, yeah, and my, because that's...
I'm looking at it right now.
I'm like, whoa, okay.
because that's what rivals is like usually it's not rivals is not about like whoever technically it's like it's not really about like for esports it's not about who has the best individual play like best team players it's also about like the bad line too because it changes everything so it's like rock paper scissors so if they if someone messes up the bad line if a team messes up the bad line it's over because the other team has a better comp that can rock paper scissors your comp so it's literally like a mind game all right i guess we'll we'll see how it goes in this final best of three good luck and thanks for putting on the show so far yeah thank you thank you for having us i did not see myself in the final so i'm hey yeah we're here good luck good luck good luck thank you thank you guys bye-bye bye-bye bye no oh my god we're back good interview back oh all right all right time almost time let's do it so this is the back to back to back right yeah
oh are we ready yeah let me type r in the game i didn't realize they were typing it in the lobby We didn't even press R.
I readied up.
Realize, breathing.
I know somehow I'm gonna get there and be so wonderful.
It's all for real.
I hear them.
Team doobsters?
You ready?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
we know who we're banning yeah i i know what we're banning i think give me a sec let me idea pull it up yeah i know what we're banning i almost forgot i i'm extremely whoa it's this thing again now it's professional oh my shit okay wait wait a minute oh this one wait a minute i gotta pull up we have three bans three bet wait i don't know no they can put ring they can put ring stuff here yeah oh okay yeah yeah no no no no no this this it's because it's best of two or best of three best of three all right jeff time best two out of three on it or just first of three okay are you a lord is that a lord wait that's a good question is it first of three or best out of three best of three best of three them all right let's see what they're gonna ban i'm curious what are you gonna do here what's they banning what they bad this is the bat like i'm curious what their new bad line is gonna be oh okay i knew it i knew it okay i knew it i think they're gonna ban fantastic next is this the name room
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah those are good bands we did last time if it doesn't work we can i like when we ban hella because like i like when we ban hella because i can still play no more yeah more all right let's see okay oh my god all my damn support all right i'm not judging
oh this is domination okay all right so if they run they might run wolf here okay so that's why i think that's why they take the push they take the seal away so they could have a chance to run well if they pick wolf should i go back to group because i could just not get picked up no you don't go grew when you're when you're against or do you feel confident do you feel confident going against wolf yeah yeah because with the new change to his e i can't get grabbed anymore so if he can't and i'm on i'm a mantis i'm a mantis yeah yeah do it i'm mantis i think it would be okay yeah if it doesn't work just watch the yeah no if i if i need if we need a yeah if we need a shield take i can go um strange oh they might need to pause i get my i get my answer yeah pause please okay we'll just i'll do an ad oh wait well we have to run up and we'll run up until they pause there you go they got it okay because we don't know if they're running as well that's the thing like at this point they should
just reset the lobby and just keep the same end yeah oh they're not running okay i wasn't i wasn't sure if they were running or not i just opened mouse stream and they were they were in fact we're closer than they oh oops all right now don't reset the lobby hold on
the hero selection area so oh nice nice i just jumped oh i lost my phone where's my phone oh no jack can you call my phone so i can find it that'd be terrifying if it actually rings hello oh i think she had the same problem as us where she has to reset the we just restart That's great.
Yeah.
Oh, I think I left it in my kitchen.
Well, then I have my second phone here to watch TikTok.
Jesus Christ, bro.
Second phone.
Oh, my God.
I just bought an iPhone, so I've been watching TikTok.
You're so ill, dude.
You're actually ill.
You're brain-rotted.
Yeah, I am.
Okay.
Oh, they're good.
They're good.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Just are you all ready?
Are you all ready?
Just click confirm you're all ready.
Yep.
All right.
Ready to go out.
Let's roll out.
Woohoo.
He's got the double phone strat.
That's how you know he's single.
That's dirty and rude.
That's facts, though.
I've been playing, I've been playing eight ball in this bitch, bro.
I think I got damage.
These women be cooking my shit.
Oh, they play Groot 2.
What's up?
Oh, shit.
I'm low.
That's fine.
His wall's broken.
Oh, my wall broke because of the moving wall.
Careful, careful.
Help our group.
I'm good.
Not good anymore.
Okay, she's boxed.
She's boxed.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay, bye.
Blur, I'll stab you in the chest.
I think that's gotta go against code of conduct or something, dude.
You can't be saying that.
I mean, in game.
Low key in game.
Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
We got group.
All the healers are cut off.
Nice, nice, nice.
Push up, push up, push up, push up, push up.
You're down, they're down too.
Whop his ass.
Oh, no, come back, come back, come back, come back, come back now.
I'm all here.
I have all here.
We'll use my alt first.
Let's let you.
And then if, if the storm alts, you copy me.
Uh, so.
He should be close to, if not.
They're getting, they got a squirrel girl now.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go.
There it is.
Do I copy?
Yeah, copy me.
Copy me.
Oh my god.
I can't see you.
That was so many support ults from them.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna die here.
I'm gonna die here.
It's fine.
They're running Sharknado.
You can go in with Mantis.
That was so many ults.
It's okay.
For Sharknado, we just shoot the...
It's good.
You didn't copy me because I didn't realize they have Jeffnado.
That was my bad.
Okay.
We...
We still run with Mantis, no?
All right.
We run Mantis.
Mantis Iron Fist Alt first.
Okay.
Okay, ready?
Copy me.
Copy me, copy me.
Go compare them.
Go.
Help them.
Help him.
Push up.
Down three.
No more.
Clear.
Klingling!
Evan!
I strapped!
That looked like a failed alt.
It wasn't.
The second I ulted, I knew he would waste his two.
And he got nothing for it.
That grab was like, that was like so accidental.
Because tanks are literally monkeys, so monkey see, monkey do.
He's like, oh yeah, I can do that.
Okay, net rocket.
I'll let whenever they do it.
off you was uncut off almost got out ow I'm taking a lot of damage storm storm storm storm storm storm storm storm storm storm storm oh my god okay we get emma no more else no more else no more else no more else good good good good good good good some reason alright next all is my all They're gonna might use Jeff NATO if they use Jeff.
We all disperse if they use Jeff NATO.
Don't stand close together.
And we all shoot the- They're TPing, they're TPing, TPing.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna all right here then.
Ooh, I'm so high in the air.
I'll stand next to you just in case.
Yeah, I'm gonna damage boost you.
Okay.
When he dropped down, I will- Above, above, above.
Oh, my God, what?
Okay.
Oh, I'm gonna put them down, okay.
I'm here, I'm here.
We're down, we're down, we're down.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Rocket ult!
Don't use anything!
Just die!
We have three ulties coming up.
We can farm...
Farm the Loki...
Have Loki farm ult.
Uh...
Keep...
Don't...
Don't heal.
Let our Loki heal.
Okay.
I'm gonna do damage boost.
I have to do that for you though.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, guys, back up, back up, back up.
We have Loki all here.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I definitely shouldn't have done that.
I should have done that.
I bet.
Okay, but what if we take this guy?
Strange, what you doing, man?
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm here.
We can do it.
We can go.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I have rest.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
They're down.
We have rest.
Come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
I'm dead.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're even.
They are penny.
They got plenty.
I'm switching.
I'm playing Storm.
Storm.
I'm going to portal.
Yeah, portal.
Portals.
I'm going to be...
Keep me up.
Okay.
You're on the point.
Touch, touch, touch, touch, touch.
Nice.
I'm coming, but I'm one.
Alt.
check watch just get the okay penny down penny dead penny dead penny dead keep going keep going help us help us protect us protect us he got supports he got supports shoot the jeff shoot the jeff shoot the jeff he went through his puddle they're done one done one done one we can make this work make it work Oh,
we're still touching.
We're still touching.
Ow, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Okay, we have to swap here.
We have to swap Loki off.
He's just farming, abusing the, he's abusing the Moon Knight all here.
Okay.
We save Rocket for Jeffnado.
I think.
Like, that, the Moon Knight just abused the fact that we have clones.
And he farmed Moon Knight all way too many times.
times.
I'm going back to Emma.
We might need mag out for the Jeff ult.
You might have to go mag for that.
You have to save your mag out just for the Jeff eat.
Because no one else, no one else can kill the Jeff right now.
Or should I go cloak for the Jeff ult?
Do they have a mag?
Were they running mag?
No.
No, okay.
It's fine.
If you run through, he would go cloak and then make sure you cloak us.
If he...
Young man wolf still, they have an Emma and a strange, I think?
No.
All right, you guys still fine with Wolverine?
We're fine with...
I think this will work.
I'm going to...
This doesn't work.
I'll switch to Mag.
Okay, I'm going to keep Save Mantis, but if it doesn't work, I'm swapping to Luna.
Okay.
I also don't mind playing Tink.
Yeah, I can swap with you if you want to.
Just call...
You call it, I'll move around you, dude.
Okay.
Or I can Hawkeye, because they're all far back and no one's really putting a lot of pressure on me.
I don't mind playing Mag.
I can Mag.
They're running Penny now?
I hear it.
Yep.
Can we get unks, unks?
I got it, I got it.
I got it.
I can't get.
Oh shit.
Oh my help.
Why am I low on my cell phone for a second?
We can push up a little.
We have um, fine.
Okay, okay.
No more, no more, no more.
I can't really go in.
Yeah, they're, they're getting all they're getting it for free.
We let them have it for free.
Oh, we just used it up.
Cloak up, cloak up, cloak up, cloak up this cloak.
Damn, what?
You got this shit already?
Yeah, that's why.
All right, look.
We can get, we can get a, Emma, Emma, Emma.
I got her, I got it I killed her.
I'm dead.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got it.
Spread out.
Spread out, spread out.
And then kill him after.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh no, that's okay.
We didn't need that.
Oh, wait.
We do, neverm.
Neverm.
I missed the fuck.
It's fine, it's fine.
Can't get him.
All right.
We're going to use my ult to engage here.
I can ult you?
Okay.
I have ults also but we could probably save mine.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go.
You're kiting.
They're going to try and kite it.
Good one.
Oh, I got it.
Kite out.
Kite, Kite, Kite, Kite.
She's alone.
Kill this.
Panty, Panty, Panty.
Panty.
Oh, wait.
I'm holding them to the wall.
What the hell's going on?
It's just the map's moving.
God damn it.
We don't have support else here.
We have to.
I'm low.
I guess I got Penny.
I got Penny.
Penny dead.
He ate me.
I died.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't kill him.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna need mag.
Swap to mag.
Swap to mag here.
I saw you believe.
Oh, go, go, go, go.
We need mag up for the Jeff.
For Jeff.
Yep.
And the cloak too.
I have my ult.
We can push with it.
Do they have shields?
No.
They're gonna have Munayel though.
Okay.
We have to shoot it.
We just have to shoot it.
We batted it.
Shoot it.
Oh, we have to shoot that.
Give me the moon knight!
Yes!
Emma 1, Emma 1, Emma 1, Emma 1!
Emma 1!
She's grabbing me!
aquiloed off this!
Actually, yeah, click-all.
Click off, click on.
And then Adam stay alive.
Oh, you have res, you have res?
You have res.
Yeah, I'm out of res.
Adama's first.
and i come in oh he wants you it's fine ready i'm going in are we all here yeah yeah go go go go
oh my god this blur storm is crazy but you have focus on blur we can put up emma emma focus emma focus emma right here i'm alone on point emma focus emma focus emma focus emma on me on me she's fucking looping me there you go
have storm melt we don't have support all for this so we all have to shoot the storm if anything yeah they switched they switched the they switched their tp they're tp they're gonna have storm melt we have no support else we have to shoot it they're nowhere near the tv because they're trying to fight me so bad we are gonna have to if they run this again we have to run luna instead of cloak i don't think cloak is working okay okay i'll switch to luna if i die yeah they're gonna Oh,
here.
They're gonna have Moon Knight, so careful.
Get feet.
Mag, remember to get rid.
Get rid.
Here, here.
Oh, what?
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Oh, blur you bitch.
He's fucking ultimate on top of me.
I'm getting fucking juggled.
Oh, I'm gonna swap.
Someone has to swap to Strange.
Okay, okay.
Actually, I got it.
I got it.
Someone guard me?
What?
Oh, my God.
It's not working.
I'm sorry.
My thing bugged.
Oh, no.
Unlucky.
It's okay.
It's only one.
We just forgot two more.
My thing bugged out.
Good try.
I was trying to portal and then my keys bugged out there.
Yeah.
Hmm.
You want to still keep me on DPS then?
I feel like we were able to.
I need something to contest about Moon Knight.
Moon Knight's just getting fucking hell of re-damage.
I'm able to contest Moon Knight.
I think Jeff is way too disruptive right now.
Okay.
All right.
him next time it's just this map is a jeff map this is a jeff met yeah okay okay okay yeah don't worry he's still got two more we've done worse
the thing is we mean you're we have to swap loki off
we have to focus on okay let me figure out this band line because we don't want to give them bucky no we keep that dead we have to keep the bucky band and the thing is we have to shoot on the map we have to shoot the storm that's like we pick we pick the map oh we picked on this one oh um how much time do we have 27 seconds we have 30 seconds oh fuck i didn't know we were gonna pick the map are we doing convergence of convoy do convoy we do convoy we should do convoy which one oh let's do tokyo actually no they have a storm player um i'm thinking his guard both suck so i mean all three suck a storm so you might as well pick tokyo or his guard all right oh wait i'm trying to pick it oh did it pick it for us oh hello are we nope it picks random what i picked it what this wasn't even on the this wasn't even on We're in China.
I cannot be late.
Can we reset?
Let me pick.
It didn't let me pick.
Well, good news.
This is not a Jeff map.
So we don't have to worry about banning Jeff.
Okay.
I'm going to banish from this match.
We do Bucky still.
Yep.
Uh, but we let's just pause.
Yeah.
We'll do pause soon.
Okay.
If they first ban Gambit, we ban Storm.
Hello.
Hey.
Okay.
We ban Storm.
All right.
Be, be, be, be, be, be, be, be,
be, be, be, be, be, be, be, be, this is?
Yeah, this is.
Oh, wait, this is the Helen map!
Benhella!
Now, no, no, no!
Hela, all of you guys, hela!
Hela!
Hela, Hela!
Bannhella!
And then we'll be like, the bann...
the gotcha messed up.
We actually wanted to ban...
We can make it work.
We can just play Hanna.
Hanna, can you... Can we honor that?
We had a joke.
Yeah.
Majority of us pick.
fuck no they're gonna say no we're gonna need to restart this if we want to do that yeah
i didn't really realize i mean we can handle hella if they don't hella instead of storm is our bad line but they can't get storm we have to we have to restart oh we don't yeah can we restart lobby and restart and you'll honor honor the map 30 seconds before you attack get ready i'll do it yeah we'll honor same bands the same bands same bands and same maps all right except for hella over storm yeah there you go that's unfortunate for sure i forgot that we were on that map it's okay it's okay they want to know if you're ready
yeah all right we have to we have to down hard because that was the whole map too this sucks my lap my thing lagged i couldn't like pick it it was it only me was i the only one allowed to pick the map yeah yeah Oh, they're here.
We're in China.
.
Wow, you're more Chinese than I am.
You've caught me in a very Chinese part of my life.
.
I like to pick Jeff.
What are we doing?
It doesn't matter.
It's okay.
So, Ben.
Ben, Bucky, Hella.
We just got to honor that.
What's the support that you want me on?
If they run, we run Loki first.
If they run Moon Knight, you swap off of Loki instantly.
For Res, you have to wait until two people die and don't Res in the middle of the point.
That's really it.
But like, the most ideal playing against Storm, we have to play Luna.
That's the most ideal.
But with that, your hero pool is so fucking limited because if we play Luna, you have to play it either.
We could try and make Adam work, but I also have to swap to something else.
Because we need to play Luna against, like, Storm.
Okay.
I can't, we can go...
okay we can try and go rocket luna loki for now rocket luna loki yeah
hmm i like this i like this all right we got this so luna will focus on the will focus on alting for storm and we have to i think if they have a storm we need a hit scan we need a hit scan you need do you know i put Punisher, Heavenly?
Yeah.
Okay.
We might have to run Emma.
Emma Punisher.
I'm Emma Punisher.
Or, yeah, sir.
You want me to swap off now?
Yeah, I need you to be on Punisher.
If you're on Storm.
Or do you know I play Phoenix?
Phoenix is the best character against Storm.
I haven't played her yet.
It's fine.
We can try and make this.
Yeah, yeah.
need to do is capture the missionary kind of unfortunate because don't go too far don't go too far don't go too far don't go too far yeah there's no reason to play i'm gonna use this real quick yeah yeah up top up top up top we need someone to oh the server is lagging okay it's fine it keeps lagging on this map specifically i noticed too much fog they have a storm We have a storm but our Punisher is gonna be dealing with that.
That fucked up so bad.
My hook did not.
Hopefully we're supposed to hook.
Oh good, oh good, okay.
We have Rez, we have Rez.
Yeah, we're up.
Can we get Moon Knight up there still?
I can't get him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They both focus me at the same time.
Oh, behind, behind.
Yeah.
Storm.
Storm's up close.
Don't even be able to kill her.
No, I can't get her!
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
She's dead, she's dead!
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Go, keep going, keep going, keep going with that.
Keep going now.
I'm okay, I'm okay here.
I'm dying.
I'm going to .
I'm going to all here.
Keep going.
It's fine.
This is real firepower.
We're down.
Jeff down.
He's like, oh.
They're down two, down two.
Petty down three, down three.
Get the cloak, like the cloak, like the cloak.
Nice.
Here we go.
Okay.
When use the, if they storm out, use the use the bind for Adam, like the soul link.
Use the soul link for them.
Yeah.
The mob.
But don't don't move on when you hear it.
the ult so bond when you when you see the alt comes out and so bond not when she not when she starts it when she puts it down yeah got it almost have res we soap on and if our if it looks like we're still dying oh it's fine it's fine it's fine that's on me okay okay nice okay okay yeah they'll have I got moon night.
Nice, nice, nice.
Don't hesitate.
Yo, spinny's on the side.
I need help.
They did not let me capitalize on that.
Here, I got you.
I got you.
Spinny's shit's on the side.
Lurr don't make me do this!
Do it.
You have to.
You have to kill him.
You want the money.
You want the money so bad, you're gonna kill him!
Okay.
We have...
Yeah.
So if I can't, oh no, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I can't, I can't ulti.
I couldn't.
It's fine.
Just die.
Just never use nothing.
Use nothing.
Oh, don't use anything.
Don't use anything.
Don't rest.
We got to regroup.
Oh, no.
Heavenly.
No.
I was already way too far out.
Okay.
It's fine.
We'll use my ult to engage.
All right.
You guys ready?
Yep.
Okay.
I need heals here.
All right.
Here we go.
What is happening?
That's fine.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got Emma.
Push up, push up, push up, push up, push up.
Push up, push up, push up, push up.
Don't get hit by the nades.
Oh, that was my bad.
I should have been like, careful.
Shoot the...
What?
I'm lagging.
I was trying to shoot the thing.
I would, I'm lagging really bad.
Can you can raise this?
Rest this, rest this.
Oh, it is lagging.
This is laggy.
We have numbers.
We have numbers now.
Nice, nice, nice.
Keep going, keep going.
Behind me, behind me, behind me.
Penny, Penny, focus on Penny.
Penny's one.
Penny is one, Penny is one.
Penny is one.
Got her, got her, got her.
There is.
Someone up here.
Get the cloak.
Focus on cloak.
Nice, nice.
I got her, I got her.
I got her.
Yeah, save the Loonol for any for defensive.
Just use it for defensive.
Just don't...
Somebody's coming around underneath.
It's fine.
I'll look.
I have ulti.
I have ulti for it.
Lagging.
Yeah, I'm lagging too.
Nice.
Use this.
You have to use this.
You have to, so you don't get eaten.
Hit me here.
I'm here.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I have...
I got it.
Nice.
Good play.
They're using Cloak all.
Fuck.
it's okay it's okay it's okay no it's not that i could have one shot cloak but she webbed me and i know you had to choose between cloak or jeff what the fuck okay oh i'm trying to heal oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh oh no oh I'm dead.
It's okay.
We're still good.
I can't leave you.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm coming back.
Oh, thigh lock.
Oh, behind you guys.
Behind you is a moonlight.
Support behind you is a moonlight.
Moonlight, Moonlight.
I got him.
I got him right here.
Sorry, Blur.
Can we get, can we get?
I got her.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Emma, Emma, Emma.
Penny, penny, penny.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Good shot.
Vehicle reached a checkpoint.
Keep up the momentum.
How far up do we want to push?
One person on card.
The rest of us be here.
We gotta push it right here.
You should go QQ.
Yeah, you should build your alt.
Build your alt.
Your alt is one point.
I heard Phoenix.
Scylic's coming around here.
Scylic's coming around.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, he destroyed our res.
So we don't have res.
We don't have res.
Just remember.
I have my alt.
Shobana, soobana, soobana, soobana.
Nice.
You're so blind.
Ghost for one.
Nice.
Blurred.
Push up if you can.
Hook, please.
Cloak is one.
Mag one.
MA one.
Any heals?
Thank you.
Nice.
Emma dead.
Pushing, pushing, pushing.
This lag will be the death of you, man.
It's bad.
It's really bad.
And I agree.
I bubble for you.
Phoenix on the left side.
Nice.
We're dead.
Push, push, push, push.
Kill these guys.
You kill this?
Nice.
They'll pop too.
Use it.
Hide.
Don't fight this.
Uh, Emma's on me.
It's fine.
I'm with you.
No.
She was fine.
I got it.
focus on max focus on max okay okay okay nice nice nice nice Sime dynamic one night please this is a very fair match i feel like they we've whipped our asses the first time and like yeah i like to still feel like i'm getting my ass oh we run we run pin here yeah somebody's able to stay on high ground i can stay in the high ground with you for uh meetup going high ground no no hawkeye okay yeah because he has to make sure high up high ground is contested okay okay heavenly um what's up did you hear that you have to go high ground you have to stay on top of that thing in the on the first point sure thing boss you want me on mag still yeah mag mag is always the best main tank got you got you well
okay I will chuck my heels up on high ground if you need it.
Got you, got you.
I don't even know where to stand here, to be honest.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna just...
You stand, support's just stand.
You stand with our Luna.
That's really it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You just hold one lane.
Yeah, you don't, you try not to...
My bad.
Yeah, this is good.
This is good.
see if they push the other way and you have to go the other way we'll rotate through the center moon night okay that's fine okay hunks
if you need help somebody's on top of the center somebody's on top of the center holy fucking moon night duel there oh my hook i fell that's fine i pushed off my blur um penny can you contest the high ground yes i can yeah contest it contest it oh i can't get up there what the okay help out of our luna help our luna nice nice nice nice nice nice nice Let's get this.
All right, you can draw up.
You can leave the high ground now, cause our, Does structure.
Okay, okay.
Got it.
There's no res, there's no res.
You're walled off.
You have the high ground.
There's no res, there's no res.
Bro, get down!
There's no res.
I'm gonna scrub all over here too.
What the heck?
Bon !
Bon, so bon!
So bon.
Yeah, yeah, nice, nice, nice.
You left that.
Trying to help.
On the other side, he's alone.
He's alone.
One's low.
Someone's low.
Aval.
Save mag.
Save all mags.
Wait for this.
I don't.
No more else.
No more please.
Thank you.
Get the support.
Nice.
I got one.
you know what, we gotta build all here.
Careful, careful, careful, build, you're gonna wall off.
Careful, careful.
Okay, I have my ult, I can stall.
Do we want the second nest near this fort?
Yeah, give it, put it in them.
Don't put it in the open, don't put it in the open.
I got a switch, I got a storm.
There's a storm, there's a storm.
Storm's losing.
Nice kill.
Youzhu hide, youzhu hide, youzhu hide, just hide.
Just hide.
You can ult this if you can it's isa isa i have all this isa okay got it got it coming just all this isa break the squirrels break the squirrels if you can
nice i was a zoning all i got them all that's fine i have i have res i have res rest here rest here rest here oh never mind don't rest don't rest don't rest don't rest okay never mind okay rest rest now rest now rest now rest now rest now i didn't have i didn't have ulti i didn't have ulti no you rest me i was trying ride and switch.
It's fine.
Fight this.
We're fighting it.
Nice.
They're off.
Healers are one.
Storm behind us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just...
She's one.
Nice.
I helped it.
No more else.
No more.
No, Jeff, please.
Jeff, please.
He's in the floor.
We're putting them back.
I'm alting them.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, Nice, awesome.
Nice, nice, nice, good, good, good.
Two dead.
Yeah, 30 seconds.
I have res here.
I'm gonna find a good place to res.
Down to 30 seconds.
I hear the Jlass, I can hear him.
It's okay.
He doesn't have ulti.
He's just in the back.
Careful,ight.
Kable, you're pushed off by yourself!
I'll catch you up!
I'm just farming your ulti.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, that's good.
That's good.
I bubble.
random bullshit go okay then we're gonna they're gonna force they're gonna force they're gonna try to touch yeah nice they're down one they're down one I can't I can't I'm dead it's fine oh they took my portal they took my portal first person to die portal first person I got it I got it I got it I got it yeah yeah I can strange.
I can strange.
I'm already on it.
Why wouldn't it click?
I couldn't ult.
It's fine.
We have portal.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, they came through the portal.
Don't come out.
Jesus, leave, leave, leave, leave.
Don't get in.
Oh.
No.
What?
They swallowed me.
I couldn't.
I couldn't jump into portal.
Okay.
So the thing is, we have to, you just don't have to go to a portal for us.
You wait.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
what the was good all good i think it's you want to say you can do hot guy for against the group right yeah yeah i can switch now i was only playing uh there was no walls i don't want to go penny anymore their group is breaking my yeah just yeah i'll stay on rocket rocket's been working
oh uh this is a nice spot oh damn blur he's in your face he wants you come here come here i got You guys gotta help us.
I got a blood.
Kill him.
Guys, help him.
Somehow the fucking sharks.
Should we drop down?
I have all here.
I'm gonna use it.
Drop down.
Well, here in three, two, one.
Blurred is no fucking way, dog.
We're not doing this, big dog.
Change.
Change one, change one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Group,
group, please.
Group, group, please.
Got him, got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Right side, right side.
All right, Yuzu, you hide for this fight.
You hide for this fight.
Luna, don't ult.
We all get wiped.
We don't use ults.
Yuzu, hide.
We all get wiped.
Let them use every ult they can.
And then we...
Got it, got it, got it.
We're here to bait ults here.
Oh, it's okay.
We have res.
You don't have to reuse for res.
Uh, what's going on top again?
He's going in our back lane.
Yeah, okay.
Just die, just die here.
Die here.
Let us die here.
Fight it death.
Nice, nice.
I'm molting.
Brace list.
Oh no.
.
Oh my god.
Oh, I.
Oh, I thought this...
Oh, nice.
That was just a good counter-all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We had to...
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
They used a lot of us.
We still have Luna.
We have Luna and Emma.
They used Groot Vult.
We still have a lot.
We can contest.
Um, they...
Yeah, no, I have to play.
They only have Screen Job.
You keep Luna all for Strange.
Keep Luna all for Strange.
That's all you need to do.
We get Emma all this as well.
Oh my god!
I want to keep my ulti for Punisher.
That's okay.
Yeah, if it was like a done deal, yeah, we didn't have to mag that.
Win this.
I'm alting this.
Nice, nice, nice!
They don't have...
Cloak out!
They don't have Cloak out!
We win this!
Alting!
Nice.
Focus on my L.
They're on the back.
Support, support, support, support.
Yes!
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Focus on Jeff.
He's a slippery one.
Can we get the rocket ulti, please?
I'm getting it.
I'm on it.
Thank you, thank you.
Focus, Jeff, please.
Jeff is the only one with ult.
Nice.
Got him.
He'll be back.
Here comes Rocket!
Chef is coming back, dude!
Shrek is one!
Grszyst is one!
Gricious one!
Gr mammal!
Nice, nice!
Rocket!
Shrek!
Shrek, Shrek, Shrek!
Shrek, Shrek!
Rock it, Rock it, Rock it!
Nice.
Oh, my God, nice.
Oh, my God!
Holy shit.
Go to DPS.
Good job, guys.
Thanks for swaps.
Sorry about that, Red, guys.
No, no, it's okay.
That's why it's like you have when we say like...
They literally just countered your rows.
It's not your fault.
He just had to like...
Uh, we just keep this comp.
Good job, head ass.
Okay.
Unless they start target batting, we could play other comps.
Yep.
Oh, oh my god, that was awesome.
That was awesome.
Okay, so you see, when I say like, hi for res, you just go like, not even close to us, basically.
already yeah it's like you go like uh uh you just like hide essentially like you make sure that they can't find you away from the fight yeah yeah you just have to be away from the fight but not too far away but for if you res before the portal you rest outside the portal and then you go in okay okay that's how you do the res this is it it's convergence
she picks her team picks It'd be kind of cool if they did use guard again or you just so My least favorite of these is Tokyo.
Oh, hello.
Where are we going?
Okay, we run we run three three Run three three.
Okay.
Got it.
Do you guys remember what the three three is the the Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah Oh, is this not an Angelina?
What did we ban here?
We've been do you want Ben Bucky or hella a hella or stern here?
I don't think bucky and then storm you say that and then we get our ass whoops I don't want to leave the no more team up though oh for the snap yeah I mean that's a good point doesn't fantastic on click lucky for me yeah yeah yeah yeah all right we'll do hella then for the team to get rid of the team up we're doing hella right like a soft counter eight though wait wait if he's yeah wait hold on if he's playing fantastic we don't need to ban hella if fantastic is three yeah let's well i don't think they're gonna ban your fantastic i'm gonna be i'm gonna keep they didn't ban fantastic though i don't i don't i don't want one i want one of them gotta go hella it's all right hella okay hella hella or storm we do hella right hello hello okay wait is this is this a is this a jeff map can that guy just wreck our shit again get rid of storm um yes 50 50 well let's see what i think we'll do fine it's fine you pick hella you'll pick hella oh you pick oh hot oh wait okay they didn't ban my they
man your bit so we can run our life energy is a powerful we run this okay and they actually lock in my lock him lock him and make him sorry come on heavenly lock in and make him sorry
The thing is, we're attacking.
So the moment we see a Moon Knight, you can come back and swap.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Tell him he's going to rue the day.
If we need to, you can go Invis and I can go Rocket.
Alright.
Actually, here, he has attacks.
Oh, it's this one.
Oh, I didn't even realize it was this one.
That's why we run 3-3 after you.
Okay.
Wait, are we not?
Okay, not now.
And defense.
In defense.
Okay, what do we do?
doing now then is she still running fantastic uh yeah yeah do this it still works it still works okay okay okay get your packs in the swap actions give me my snack from the snack machine if they run moon night i think triple deeps was working too or like do it yeah or we swapped the dps to moon night four three two one all right let's see what they're doing i hear a spider-man Oh,
no, that's the map.
Oh, you're being locked.
There is an Ironman.
Ironman.
Ironman, Ironman, Ironman.
Oh, he's so low.
He's so unlucky.
That guy was one HP.
I just needed to hit a third shot.
Help, up.
Help, or Emma.
Help or Emma.
I can't do any.
Okay, nice.
I just got kicked into the enemy team, but now they're walled in.
I don't have Involm.
No, I'm good.
It's fine.
Oh, we might.
I got Flour.
I think I'm going to play Mag into this.
We can still triple tank, but I'm going to play Mag.
No, we don't triple tank on offense.
No, no, it's fine.
We can still triple tank this.
It's fine.
No, just keep it, keep it, keep it.
I have ult soon.
They have two characters that can be kind of a Mag.
Altus?
It's fine.
I'll put as many walls between us and her.
Spread out.
You got nothing?
Kill Jeff?
We can.
Oh, she lives.
We got Ironman.
Ironman one.
He's gone.
I have copies, dude.
I have copies.
Copy me.
I'm copying.
Push up.
Pushing up.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's just...
Fuck.
Got the healers.
Nice, nice, nice.
Good, good, good, good.
Nice, nice.
Help our group.
It's fine, it's fine.
There's a group.
There's one.
Got him.
Emma's low.
Emma's one.
Help me.
Oh, that's my bad.
I really wanted that Emma kill.
Help her.
Yeah.
I was overextended.
Both Mia and Isa were too hungry for the healers.
My bad.
Yeah, no.
I was, I wanted it too.
I just ran straight for fucking cloak.
I was like, I'm eating it.
Looks good.
I didn't.
I didn't want to be.
I got all this, I got all this.
No, no.
Oh, no.
I'm Eden.
I got it to save the...
I'm saving you for fun.
Okay, Punisher, okay.
I can go Moon Knight right now.
Yeah, go Moon Knight, go Moon Knight.
There's no reason.
Okay, well.
Finisher.
Oh, never mind.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, Iron Man, top.
Iron Man top, Iron Man top.
I can't...
Nice, nice, nice.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
They're down to both DPS.
Keep going.
Yeah, yeah.
Help her.
You gotta be.
Okay, nice.
I'm choked.
Oh, he's fine.
Get the grip.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I got kicked.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna copy.
Yeah, yeah.
Copy me.
Where's the Ironman?
Ironman behind us.
Behind us.
Focus on Ironman.
He's hiding.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna look.
I'm gonna keep my, I don't know.
I don't know.
They're cloaked.
my gosh nice i got their i got their gear i got their gear i got their gear iron man iron man focus on iron man again focus on iron man he's low he's low they're not on a they're only one on the point nice he's dead he's dead i'm alting i'm alting this jaffa's alting jaffa's alting spread out i'm i'm i got grabbed i got grabbed i got grabbed i'm inside i'm pushing it in i'm pushing it in i'm using my ult to push it in i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead there's a there's a portal portal we have to portal we have to portal i'm portaling i'm portaling i'm portaling If you can just back up,
don't die.
Loki, don't die.
Don't die.
You can.
Okay.
Don't die.
Just...
I'm trying to.
Okay.
He's gonna have...
He's gonna have Iron Man all here.
Oh my gosh.
I blocked it.
Oh my god.
I'm going to...
Can we get a...
Can we get...
That's fine.
Where's the rest?
We have a rest.
Iron Man.
Jury, executioner.
Play around card.
He can die.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Emma, one, Emma, one.
Ironman on me.
I'm shooting Ironman for you.
He's one.
Ironman dead.
Groot, Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Focus on Groot.
Focusing.
He is very little.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
All right, all right.
I'm going to stay on.
I'm going to stay on record.
Come here.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, they're on.
Okay.
We gotta save.
We gotta go back to Mag here.
We alt and one of...
Use Strange alt first and then go to Mag.
Okay.
And then we have to swap...
Oh, wait.
We can actually...
I think Luna's better.
I'm gonna go...
I alt and then...
They switched to Storm.
Yeah, yeah.
We need Mag and I'll swap to Luna.
I'll swap to Luna.
Yeah.
Are you our only Flyers defense or do we need a DPS his game?
I can switch we can anyway blur back the fuck up.
I can switch Yeah, I'm good.
Help, help, help, help.
One of them fell off.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
No more.
No more, no more, no more.
No more else.
Got it.
Just we win this.
We win this.
It's time to face your fear.
Get that puncher.
Nice.
Push card.
Three on card.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Back off, back off.
I'm gonna use all here.
You're walled, you're walled.
Billy, look, you're walled.
I'm gonna use all here.
Here for, uh, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, I hear it.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, I hear it.
Jeff, I hear.
Jeff, I hear it.
There he is.
Spread out.
I couldn't get up.
What the fuck is going on, man?
I'm gonna get tossed off.
He's okay.
It's okay.
He's dead though.
He's dead.
I'm dead.
I want the storm.
Get the storm.
I'm your man.
Nevermind.
I don't know if I should anymore.
Oh no, you did double copy.
It's bad.
Just try.
Got to try and try.
I'm gonna try to back off here.
I'm gonna go Luna.
I'm going Luna here.
Okay.
Back off, back off, back off.
Back off.
Oh my god.
One DPS though.
They're done.
One, one, one, one, one, one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Push up a bit.
They have to back up.
They have to kite.
They have to kite this now.
Nice, two, two, two.
They're down two, down two!
Push up, push up, push up.
Push up, push up, don't be scared.
Don't be scared.
Jack down, Jack down.
Down three.
Focus on those Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma.
She's one.
Focus on Groot.
He's by himself.
I want him.
Shoot it.
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot.
Groot,
Groot, Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Oh, I'm dead.
Storm, storm, storm, storm.
Storm, get it.
Clean, clean, clean.
Emma, Emma, Emma.
Focus fully on Emma.
She is just nice, nice, nice.
Cloak, nice.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Where's my...
Can I have my Hawk out of the back?
No.
Groot is one.
Groot's one!
Okay.
Oh, I'm so.
I almost killed him.
It's okay.
I actually almost killed him too.
I could have killed him too.
What is that?
It's a Moon Knight.
Moon Knight.
You want me to switch to Admiral there?
Oh, are you fucking serious?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Switch it.
This game sucks.
No, no more else.
Okay.
No more else.
No more else here.
Okay.
Sorry.
Unless we get a pick.
here storm pure storm i think storm my ulti swap now swap now use this swap now this is last fight uh try back off let me yeah yeah we're still good i can't do anything i it's fine just play keep playing this keep playing this they use moonlight so you can still be loki now i have next up use uh you have to use invis if you're in danger i'll save My Luna offer.
Nice, nice.
Groot, Groot, please.
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Oh, I'm blocking heals.
I'm blocking heals.
Good dead.
I'm on the back line.
I got the ammo.
Keep the storm.
Keep, keep me out.
Keep me out.
I got to be.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Keep shooting the storm.
Shoot the storm.
Shoot the storm!
Nice!
Invis!
Focus on Invis!
We can kill it!
Emma!
Focus on Emma!
Nice!
Thank you!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, my eyes are burning.
They've been open for so long.
Alright.
We won 3-3.
Okay.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep, yep.
a top-notch team to win this one you want adam yeah adam we'll do adam loki is the thing and we just have to sustain okay i just keep resing when you say that you go yeah we do this no three three three bail yeah oh sorry sorry oh oh my god oh my god i was like blanking out do you want do you want emma or uh strange uh they don't really have many projectiles besides storm and i mean yeah you guys you guys have enough shields all right after we lose first point we just swapped to what we were playing yep okay 30 seconds before you attack get ready done done we need the mag just yeah just remember the mag for the uh i hear you jam it out heavenly yeah keeps yourself calm up right here remember we can we can push up we can push up here we can push up oh yeah we push up we play around this corner yeah push up this corner this corner come on come on come on come on uh you you don't have to push up you don't have to push up you might need to do soap on for them but other than that you don't
need to push up push up um group push up a bit push up with them push up with them i was looking for flyers yeah
they have a moon nightcare yeah they're just gonna run nice pull shield up turrets up turrets down good job he's running up with me I have to put a wall on myself there's one there's hell we can push up I got a res I got a res I got a res I got a res alright
Moon Knight where was that can we get monks nice kill nice kill nice kill down one
let's keep playing this I'm backing up I'm backing out of it I have no shield.
I have no bubble for you.
I have no bubble for you, Carrie.
Just keep fighting.
Keep fighting.
Keep fighting out.
I already used my Involve.
All right.
They have a storm.
I just saw it.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
That's like the counter for it.
I'm... All right.
We'll use the...
We'll use...
If you can...
I have...
Yeah, yeah.
Use res.
You can.
If you have the...
There you go.
I'm gonna copy you and I'm gonna...
Don't...
Spread out, spread out, spread out!
Yeah, no one.
Oh.
Okay, well, he was punished anyway, sorry.
I got ult, I'm ulting.
I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you!
Oh, nice.
He used to hide, used to hide, used to hide.
He used to hide.
Heiding, hiding.
There you go.
Oh, he's boxed the fuck in amongst the dudes.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Blur one, Blur one!
Oh wait, yeah, res, res, res, res, res, res.
Oh, wait, no, actually, yeah, yeah, res this.
Oh, oh.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Laura's out of the healing.
Oh, it was too far.
It was fine.
Wait, no, I'm back!
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back!
I'm dead.
Oh, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
Just die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point.
We have to die here.
Just die here.
We're dead.
Yeah, just keep, stay, stay, stay, stay.
We stay the cop.
And then we all meet up.
We all meet up there.
And then wait, just wait, wait for us.
You want me to portal?
No.
No, no, no, no.
We just go.
We can make it.
I was so unlucky because Blur was just waiting for you, like, wouldn't let me use my olive.
Oh, there's a gap!
There you are.
Are you ready?
There's no more, Jeff.
I'm switching that thing.
Okay.
Oh, we have to go in.
You can just go in.
You can just go in there.
I'll be able to catch it.
There you go.
I'm like right.
I'm like, we have point.
We have point.
Get someone help.
Someone grab the healers.
I've separated the healers.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I have copy here.
The healers are still in the back.
They're still boxed in.
Yo, Magnus is boxing.
We can get nice, nice, nice, nice.
Back down.
Storm over here.
We get point, point, point, please.
Yeah, we get nice, nice, nice, nice.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Care, care, care.
We don't have the, we can push, we can play here.
We can play here.
It's fine.
Okay, okay.
Don't, don't save your all.
save your all for last fight save your all for last fight okay bell bell back up again back up you can back up you can back up okay nice we saved it for the last fight we save it for last fight what if the thing was blue back up around the corner we're too far yeah okay okay get ready to use the invisible when he when he lands at all i'm gonna pull him away from the point oh no no no oh i'm a magg ate it damn it all right i'm blocking him off the point oh my God,
he...
That's fine.
I'm dying!
They double healer ulted!
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, I don't want.
I can portal.
No, I got...
I got...
He...
Wait, I don't want to...
I can't.
If you can make it in time, I can...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Swap, swap, swap, swap, swap, swap, swap, swap, now.
Swaps, swap, now.
Swaps now.
Okay, okay.
Or are you going mag?
Which one you want?
You want to do mag or the deal?
I'm just saying thing.
They don't have any Jeff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're fine.
I can ground the storm and then it'll be fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Um, faster.
Okay.
Let's go.
Uh, go.
Go toe to toe with him.
Get his ass.
We have to back up fully.
Back up fully.
We don't need to feed them all.
Don't feed them all.
We wait.
We have a round and then I'm going to ult them from behind.
Sorry.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's we can.
He's not here yet.
Yeah, it's fine.
here we can poke because he's almost there i will copy and viz here you do you have to hide for this okay hiding hiding oh they tried to push me a second time i'm hiding i'm hiding nice nice help bell help bell help bell helping i'm helping this is an alt they forced their ult they forced their ulti just keep hiding it's fine it's fine it's fine we can die here die here everyone die die here die here die here die here and then you should get ready for the get ready for the res okay yeah just keep saying just keep hiding just keep hiding see we're still sustaining don't use all don't use all don't use it don't use it don't use it we just die here that's just a waste it's such a waste right start the res start the res now start oh okay yeah yeah yeah nice start the res nice oh nice what the
fuck it's up here they're down one by the way
nice i'm coming back rags dead moons dead nice heavenly still down two down two down two yeah i'm trying to keep oh no i can't contest the cloak alt where we yeah just die just die just die here just die here i'm dying here just die here just die here or go back all right that's fine they use healer ulties by the way they don't have they only have rocket ulti they only have rocket i'm going rocky here so we can have res here what the fuck get out get out get out This is so bad.
This is so bad.
It's fine.
I got Riz.
You get to pick up the Riz.
That's fine.
I have my ult for this fight.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
That bag.
Eat my ult.
Should I go?
You need to heal.
Use it if you can.
Never mind.
I'm good.
Out.
Oh, okay.
How can I?
I don't, you can, how you can.
Call you if you can.
We don't need...
Hey, no, if you can.
Get ready.
Save it, save it, save it, save it.
Use it, use it, use it, use it.
Nice.
I so bonded, but I died.
Why does he get bonus health in this?
Kick his ass!
Yeah!
You're down, down the healers.
Down all healers.
Careful, careful.
Don't play too aggressive.
You're down.
Don't play.
Back it up.
Their cloak is one.
Can we TP?
No, no, no.
We don't need it.
Gotcha, bitch.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're going to TP.
We got point.
Don't say our point.
Don't get our point.
Focus on storm.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I have all here.
I'm dead.
Nice.
We got it.
Yes!
We did it!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it!
We did it!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
The thing, oh, that's not blue.
Oh my god!
Four time MVP, look at you go dude.
Put that shit on a resume.
Oh my god!
You have officially attained bragging rights.
it slowly love now you can say whatever you want too nervous to even bro let's go good job guys i'm so proud of you guys good job oh my god that was awesome that was awesome oh my god thank you for the carry gt is everyone look at gt shout out gomez shout out shout out gomez for the
This thing is blue.
Oh, my God.
That was a really good game.
They were saying.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, good job, guys.
We had to counter-soft so many times.
We mastered 3-3, too.
We mastered it.
That was my first time doing 3-3 outside of our, like, one tryout.
We freaking did it, guys.
Wow, you guys are so...
Wow, amazing.
You guys are correct.
Doki, yeah, that's so sick.
Can you come to the Mouse and Monkey Show?
Can I bring my team?
Yeah, let's all go in there.
Let's all celebrate together.
Hold on, hold on.
Wait, let me ask.
Let me ask.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, my.
We were undefeated, guys.
Yeah.
We were undefeated.
That's crazy.
also apparently my stream was lagging the entire time i'm so sorry guys the final match the final match everything was lagging my game was lagging my my shout out doki with the call outs yes yes amazing shot calling thank you guys thank you my i felt like i was going my brain was like 500 miles per hour i hate thinking on the spot oh it's amazing it's amazing i'm glad it's not best of one for this turn for the finals i mean yeah yeah no this is why i like best of three because then like we can easily figure things out next game yeah oh oh my god look at us five one oh my god we did it we did it good job guys great teamwork good job everyone we all we all played a part a team game we all did all right guys give me give me one second now i will bring you all in there oh okay nice all of y'all all right one second
we really ate that y'all we ate yeah
oh my god you too that was great that you were able to pick up adam's stuff in like one game lord head ass lord head ass was doing some major work yeah yeah yeah oh my god they thought they thought we only had one dps player little did they know i know little did they know that guy was nasty heavenly was our secret weapon okay but they let kick you take envisa girl oh true 52 000 healing 52 000 holy yeah we all played a part congrats guys you you deserve it uh feel free to go in into the main chat,
mouse and monkey at the right time.
Okay.
Thank you.
No problem.
Let's go, guys.
Thank you.
Well, look at this.
Hello.
Well, we're all slowly coming in right now.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Oh, I think.
Yay.
I have to ask.
Yeah.
What do you do, baby?
so obviously that game was amazing first of all very fun to watch the first game it looked it looked pretty tough what was the ultimate shift you guys did in the second game to kind of change the tides oh it's easy you want to know what i did what did you do my monitor on this time that's true like i think like they the other teams didn't know we actually had a second dps player that we put on tank so when they target banned our our first dps they were like all right roll swap so then obviously heavenly has an insane hot guy and yes oh my god yeah it was crazy i mean he got target band after that yeah he was too nasty but i'm still getting that w what was the point you should have been brood in the building baby what is he talking about and yes and they obviously target band our support backline too so we had to play an entirely new we haven't really practiced with and usually had to pick up how to play adam for the last two games so really insane that she was able to do that for us it
was really cool to watch especially the fights towards the end there where it was like two people would drop from each team what what kind of comms are you giving to stand to like in that situation or are you just shutting up and let them do their thing kill oh i guess like when we're down too we just yeah yeah we just be like this week we have the odds to win this fight like just just or like or just die on the card like we all just die on the card saw the card as long as we can and then you know we got some time out of it and we don't get staggered or anything yeah i think most teams had like a really strong player like at least one or two but our team had really good comms and i think that's like ultimately what helped us the most we just listened when we were told what to do yeah we were really like well-rounded which is really nice i feel like we could flex into anything or like most of us could flex into any role that was required which is really helpful that i think gave us like
an advantage against the other you guys played a lot of different characters and even doki played loki at the end which we didn't see yeah we're like wait what's that about loki doki yeah it's an actual strat like the three three like three tanks three supports so i fucked up how you're supposed to play loki you're supposed to like copy the adam and then do like like basically do like a never ending res fight but then the moment i copied like the storm was like right next to me and i was like oh okay i guess no alts for anyone um but yeah no it's we are all so well rounded like we no one can really target ban us because all of us we're not really one tricks so we're able to like play other types of characters and change your comps um so i'm really proud of my team for that i noticed that you guys also didn't ban uh jeff in the other games did you feel like jeff or you had it on the control on that map he was a problem he was very disruptive it's so yeah and then we figured it out we're
just like just hold mag out for him like who the is like just slammed off the shark yeah the magneto shield seemed to address a lot of those issues but then storm also was very very frustrating it looked like for you guys to deal with yeah yeah and i think blur in general was just very hard to deal with he's just a good player Very good.
He's a very flexible player.
And there's so many moments where the healing battle just seemed like it never ended on both sides.
Everybody's like, come on, just die.
Triple support, baby.
Triple support.
Yeah.
It was kind of from like commentating, it's like, oh, he's gonna die.
No, he's just full health.
How do they happen?
Well, that was such amazing games.
I hope you guys had fun.
I know we had so much fun watching.
It was so much fun.
Thank you so much for our hosting.
You guys agreed.
so happy and so proud of you guys thank you for the invite this was awesome thank you for organizing it's really fun i'm really proud of my team i didn't expect us to go to the finals and you're such a good team leader yes amazing she was so good team leader oh god yeah i will give a shout out to our coach super gomez too because he was like he helped us out like figuring out comps and stuff with me before we went into this tournament so like huge shout out and he also like stayed around to coach some of individually some of the players as well so you need to be my coach oh man i feel so stupid though thank you thank you guys thank you thank you it was a lot of fun uh i guess a good day and uh thanks for wedding and congrats man congrats guys you guys
this was awesome shout out goat maze all right congrats guys see you guys later bye bye look how we all oh oh yeah wow we all agreed to go down here yeah oh my god ggs guys i'm so proud of all of you guys great games good job guys i mean it's so amazing i had a lot of of fun you guys are very fun to play with yeah yeah always wants to show up yeah wait gomez wants to say something to us oh okay okay whoa whoa come on oh whoa i see we stabb i mean the tournament's over so yeah it's over yeah yeah yeah yeah you come up pull up here i never doubted any of you i never doubted any of you in my fucking life you guys literally fucking did it in the beginning i literally made it the best i love marble right i forgot my fugies not hold on he is not why is this boogey that was awesome i forgot okay okay oh yeah i was i was in my seat jumping i i i was watching heavenly's pov there was a point where he dropped his own little own music he hockey ulted locked in and killed four people i was
literally jumping in my seat and it was the last push i i was on a i was on a royal palace i don't remember what map it was but like I'd never, that was like, I was too hyped.
That's awesome.
I am proud.
I'm so proud.
Everybody, we learned how to play together really well.
And I think that was like the best part of our team.
Yeah, we, like heavily, today was the first time we all played together as a team, too.
The synergy was just there.
It was just there.
I was like watching all of you just come.
completely just do everything together like it just clicked everything just clicked
oh my god guys we won we won 7.5k well not individually but you know split between six of us but 1.25 yeah 1.25k guys look at that dude okay you heard me say it i just wanted to compete yeah i just wanted to compete y'all can keep this all right i i i'll get his cut I'll do that.
You know what?
I'll take it.
It's mine.
I was actually going to ask for like 20 bucks from each one of you, but I thought it works too.
You know, that works.
No, Heavenly will pay the tab.
All right.
I'll take that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my, geez.
I'm so proud of all you guys.
It was really nice to meet all of you guys that I haven't met before, and it was really fun to play with you guys.
Yeah.
I'm so glad.
I'm not going to lie.
No, you first, please.
You're going to say something way nicer than what I'm going to say.
Trust me.
No, it's okay.
It's just coming into this.
I was really, like, nervous and intimidated by everybody.
And this felt like the most welcoming, like, group.
And I was so happy just chatting with you all and meeting you all.
I'm so happy.
Thank you guys for, like, playing with me or letting me play with you guys.
I'm so...
You killed it, dude.
You killed it.
Our MVP.
Always MVP.
Yeah, nah.
They gave me props.
You clutched them every other round.
Yeah, yeah.
You led us to the finals.
You got us to the finals.
I'm really happy that this win was with all of you guys.
It was very, very fun.
Yeah, I'm so happy.
This was great.
I uninstalled.
I will probably stay uninstalled.
Let me know if you need me to call me back in.
I'll come back a second time.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Good.
I'll see all of you guys around.
It was really nice to meet everybody new and see everybody older.
will have a wonderful night continuing to stream uh probably me for like 30 minutes all right i'll read okay yeah i'm gonna actually don't actually don't do that don't do that i can't read me now
wait go man start your stream right now go Sorry, I know.
Sorry, I'm streaming.
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
I think I'm okay.
Oh, man.
No, raid someone else.
If I'm getting off in 30, that's not wasting my raid.
You get me?
Yeah, but you can choose a different person to raid.
You are numbers.
So you can make someone's day with the number.
Oh, you know who's okay.
You know who's still gonna, I don't know if he's gonna stay live, but Blurry's live still.
Oh, yeah.
Give me Blurry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it just, it's blur flavors with the z yeah yeah that's not worth worthy right that's a worth worth yeah yeah he was locking in so hard he wanted me dead bro he like chased me across the map i'm like he actually chased me on storm he's a killer that's why i was so sad we fought against each other we should have been on the same team you two on the same team would have been too much yeah it would have been yeah you two on the same team at dps like we just you just get you'll just win that was so much fun uh ggs guys i'm gonna say goodbye to chat and everything thank you thank you guys thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you gomez yeah of course i'm proud of all of you i'm proud of all of you thank you everyone
oh my god hello um past chat this is future dokey so um you guys might not might not see me yet uh because i can't believe we started lagging in the finals like out of if um it pisses me i'm so sad i'm so sad that we started lagging in the finals it makes me so goddamn sad but again
Thank you again to Iron Mouse and Seedog for the invite.
I was so stressed out.
I didn't think I was going to make these the finals.
I thought we were going to be knocked out right away.
This was the most stressful fucking thing I've ever done.
I was honestly incredibly stressed out.
I thought I was going to lose.
So I'm so happy for my team.
I'm really happy for how well everybody performed.
Everyone was practicing so much.
And I was just like, oh no.
like I hope we'll be okay I hope I hope it will be okay guys actually let me I don't know if I restart my OBS will it I don't know I don't know if it'll work do anything I don't know it's really weird I don't know what's wrong with my internet right now I'm gonna do a test okay you're not internet test this is the future jockey run internet test no it's fine it's literally fine right now i don't understand
is it really on youtube side wait i'm trying trying again oh i'm trying again to see if it's on youtube side or if it's on my side no i'm fine my my internet's fine it's like it's at a thousand it's at 900 900 wait okay what's the upload though What is the upload?
Wait, if I Do stop stream And restart stream Will it fuck with Stream?
Yeah!
I'm what my internet Is fine.
Yeah, I'm Past future Toki is talking A past chat right now.
No clue Wait, our Are, are other channels also dying or is it just me?
Okay.
Just, it was just me.
Okay, we're gonna, what if I stop?
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna restart.
I'm gonna...
Restart.
Oh my god.
Oh, YouTube stream had some stutters too.
Maybe your star probably fixed the delay, but the VOD.
Yeah, the VOD might be cooked right now.
Okay.
I don't want to cook the VOD.
Sad face.
Okay.
reports oh is youtube down okay let's check oh shit yeah never mind yeah never mind youtube down i also checked is youtube down lamount i think it's cloud cloud there yeah i'm like what's the Whoa, that's a lot of...
Yeah, yeah, I was like, wait, that's a lot of reports right now.
Okay, not just me.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
It's not, yeah.
Yeah, it's not just me, thank God.
Is it, yeah, thank God it's not just me right now.
Whoa.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
Oh my gosh Okay guys When you Okay when we Okay when we get to the part Okay Tell me when you guys Get to the part Where I say Goodbye I talk more about tournament In good night Dragoons And then all right guys okay i'm going to talk more about the entire tournament when i when i get to uh when i get to the part where i say goodbye so as always everybody say hi i'm ready to pause check yeah we'll be around to get that blood flowing you said for me it's a bet because you deserve it thank you guys thank you for all the support that really means a lot um this is crazy i did not expect to win um i just i had like a breakdown last night because I almost dropped out of the tournament because I was under so much stress and I really appreciate the organizers and like Sea Dog comforting me because like I I had so much to lose in a way where like I I know I had so much pressure and so many eyes on me for that tournament and I legitimately thought like I don't know if we could do it like I I just
hope we win the game like all these other teams they look these players are all so so good and i'm just a support player i don't i don't know i'm just a support player i i don't know if if i can do like all like these like i don't know if i can pick up you know support doesn't have that much of an impact so i didn't know if as a supporter i could do much for my team because you know i all i could do is a little bit better like but um thank you guys thank you guys i'm happy i stayed on um i still don't know if i'm gonna do future if you two arrive those tournaments because it's very stressful with a balancing thing so um i don't know i don't know i'm like in the crossroads for it but thank you guys and yeah i'll see you guys later today for good night dragons bye bye guys bye